we heard from Marjorie Taylor green she
got swatted again and it's weird because
a lot of the people who don't like her
are exaggerating the claims saying oh
that the SWAT team didn't show that's
not swatting is swatting is when you try
to get the SWAT team to show up now we
were we were planning on leading with
this and talking just about how the
escalation's going uh and then just a
moment ago we got a big breaking story
Mark Zuckerberg I believe it was on Joe
Rogan right because this is just we're
just picking this up right now Mark
Zuckerberg said they censored the hunter
Biden laptop story at at the request of
the FBI
there is currently a lawsuit against the
government the US government Democrats
and it is led by a there's a bunch of
plaintiffs including the state of
Missouri arguing that section 230
is a violation of the First Amendment
because it gives broad censorship
authority to these platforms immunities
as well as the Democrats and members of
the government directing censorship to
these big Tech platforms
I am I imagine that they're gonna have
to amend that complaint and be like
here's a new exhibit Mark Zuckerberg
admitting they censor stories at the
behest of the government of the doj
that's absolutely crazy so we're gonna
be talking about that obviously uh you
know Civil War is a bit of a big subject
these days particularly here so
everybody take your drink I guess that's
the name of the game and uh we had a lot
to talk about before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member if
you'd like to support our work as a
member you'll get access to exclusive
segments of the Tim cast uncensored
after-hour show at 11 PM Monday through
Thursday as well as our other shows we
got more stuff coming out we've got a
new song We're launching at midnight
tonight at timcastrecords.com if you
guys are interested should be uh really
fun and exciting you know we're just
building culture
joining us to talk about all of this and
their story I know it's not a Podium it
was a lectern but everyone calls him
Podium guy so what am I supposed to do I
can't put lectern guy his Podium guy
Adam Johnson hey thanks for having me
who are you uh my name is Adam Johnson
uh married I've raising uh five boys
stay-at-home dad trying to make amend my
pronouns are hero and Patriots and I am
wearing a black v-neck there you go
what's good loving it and Tim's tweaking
your camera there's no this tattoo also
what's that tattoo so oh it says uh it
says we the people does it how long have
you had that I actually got this a
couple weeks ago very hardcore yeah yeah
all right now after fixing yourself so
you are known as the podium guy
incorrectly it's lectern guy I guess but
you want to just give a brief overview
of why that is so um I was known as
Podium guys like as like like my story
or why is it a lecture not a podium why
why why why do you have a nickname at
all
I have a nickname because uh there was a
picture taken of me during January 6th
that uh became viral came memes quite a
bit and uh they named me that because
they didn't know my name yet
I via Getty well via Getty did take my
photo there was a lot of confusion uh
they people thought that I was via Getty
because they read the the caption
underneath it via Getty so I was via
Getty for a little bit so just for
people who don't know that means from
Getty which is a photo distribution
Network and these people who don't know
anything about this saw the photo from
Getty distribution and thought via Getty
was a name and they were like this guy
via Getty so uh we had a lot to talk
about
um talking about your experience on
January 6th how all of this stuff came
to be how you ended up carrying a
lectern so uh and then obviously we had
a lot to talk about in terms of news and
this this story about Zuckerberg we'll
start with that and then we'll book Into
Your Story obviously but uh thanks for
coming this should be fun thanks we also
inadvertently pulled in George Alexander
yeah there was an accident I was just uh
driving by you know I thought I'd say hi
I was on a quest a Mystic Quest yeah to
extinguish the world's uh really the
unspoken
threat that we all know exists it may be
in this very room
I can't say you can't say it well he he
texted me and he was like bro I'm really
hungry do you have food and I was like
why don't you come over and it's like
all right pretty much listen
I I am on a Mystic Quest but I you know
it's there's it's a pretty thankless job
I know Reddit knows who I am I am the
greatest martial artist yeah on the
internet so uh George you guys know who
I am yeah also known as G Prime 85 we
have your paintings I guess you call
them paintings digital paintings up on
the walls and you make a bunch of memes
I gotta say dude the um the truck flying
into the Trade Center was one of the
funniest pieces of satire I've ever seen
satire
but it convinced a lot of conservatives
it was real oh my goodness you know uh
they still share I think in Canada the
uh the trucks with the KKK hoods on them
look it is real if you want it to be
real it's true it's the the money you
send me is real and that's all I care
about that's great right on we also got
Ian hi everybody Ian Crossland here
happy to be here let's just keep this
going I'm very excited I think listening
to the conversation before the show is
gonna be hilarious love having George
love meeting Adam let's get going so the
first story we have is actually you know
we're getting set up for the show and uh
when when news breaks right before the
show it's tough because you know I I'm
reading the news up until like four and
then I get to exercise and eat and so
we're getting up here we're pulling
stories and it's just right before the
show we get this clip Jack busovic
posted it breaking Zuckerberg says
Facebook limited distribution of the
hunter laptop story based on a general
request from the FDA FBI we're going to
play this clip for you now and hear what
Mr Zuckerberg had to say let's turn up
like there was a lot of attention on
Twitter during the election because of
the hunter Biden laptop story
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than Twitter
um I mean basically the background here
is the FBI I think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um just so you know like you should be
on high alert there was we we thought
there was a lot of Russian propaganda in
the 2016 election we have it on notice
that basically there's about to be some
kind of dump of of um uh that's similar
to that so just be vigilant so our
protocol is different from Twitter's
what Twitter did is they said you can't
share this at all
um we didn't do that what we do is we
have um if something is reported to us
as potentially
misinformation important misinformation
we we also use this third party
fact-checking program because we don't
want to be deciding what's true and
false and for the I think it was five or
seven days when it was basically being
um being determined whether it was false
um
the Distribution on Facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when you say
the distribution is decreased it got
shared how does that work it basically
the ranking in news feed was a little
bit less so fewer people saw it than
would have otherwise so it definitely in
other words Mark Zuckerberg has admitted
that the FBI came to them and said hey
watch out for this uh Russian
misinformation so they went okay hey
look here's a negative story about Biden
let's censor this because people have to
determine whether it's false and people
of course are their chosen sources he's
trying to very much downplay it I don't
want to make it seem like the FBI went
to him and said outright censor the
hunter Biden laptop story which is kind
of what my understanding was but it's
more so they came to them and said watch
out for for you know this kind of
misinformation which triggers Facebook
to then say we're going to censor some
of these stories interfering in the
election man dark days indeed is one way
to put it yeah I don't know what are you
thinking because you're you know you
worked on social media stuff you worked
on the censorship stuff um well firstly
Mark ducked the question when Joe was
like so you censored it too Mark didn't
say yes but they did and what they did
was they blacklisted the thing they put
it they they Shadow banned it they they
downranked it in the algorithm which is
a you know you could say it's an
Insidious form of censorship because the
people don't even know it's being
censored at least when it won't go
through you know it won't go through
um question about ethics of it oh also
he talks about we don't want to be the
ones that decide what's right and wrong
so we Outsource that to a third party
like that so we've decided someone else
gets to decide what's right and wrong I
don't know I think the community should
be deciding what violates terms
personally well to me it just sounds
like they're Outsourcing they're
choosing who they're Outsourcing to so
they're already so they're deciding by
not deciding they're saying we're going
to Outsource this other group we know
they're left-leaning but at least it
won't be up it's kind of like what
Pontius pilot Jesus Christ exactly you
want to wash my hands to this publicly
you know it's not me that's that's the
bad person in the room it's definitely
someone else and we're not going to tell
you who that is and kind of bury that
information but you know censorship is
good for us you know because how we know
what's true if we're not told what's
true you know you know I'm one thing I
don't like about this is like Mark it's
not a it's not a publisher the
Facebook's not a publishing platform
it's a it's like a general platform
that's allowing people to publish their
own stuff so that they take I don't know
man we're in very strange times with new
technology so laws and things need to be
Rewritten this would be like your phone
company sending you a notice being like
hey if you have a phone conversation
about Hunter Biden we're gonna shut your
call down yeah but it's a pub it's
different because it's public so they're
downranking it's visibility which is
different than not letting you have you
could still have that call we'll just
lower the volume so everybody can hear
you but that's not true either I
couldn't do a call to a loudspeaker in a
stadium full of people I'm using that
Tech to deliver a message in a Direction
Twitter was was substantially worse they
were stopping from even sharing it
between people which is like more so
like you can't call people and tell them
this but what if I do a phone call to a
conference room maybe it's a university
with a thousand people you know sitting
in an auditorium and they and we do a
phone call so that everyone can hear
what I have to say yeah be like them
saying this your call is not going to
access speaker phones we're not going to
let any speaker phones take your calls
only only individual people can hear it
or something like that I guess the
question is turn the volume down I'll
say this too as kind of a
is this a correction on on how I opened
my understanding was that the FBI made a
request for the hunter Biden Black Ops
story to be censored what Mark is saying
is they gave them a general request
about hey you should basically like they
basically told Facebook to censor
information they said that Russians are
trying to interfere wink wink nudge
nudge we know what that means I think it
was more direct than that but Mark is
clearly trying to downplay what's going
on so I just want to make sure we're
clear I don't know that the FBI told him
in a censor the hunter Biden laptop
store explicitly but the FBI did go to
Facebook and said watch out for this
stuff which they know would result in
Facebook censoring tons of information
regardless of where it came from I mean
the fact that the FBI said any
information should be under under watch
is a First Amendment violation and any
action taken after that in my I would
argue is Facebook acting on behest of
the US government it's funny like We As
Americans have First Amendment rights
but do Russians have First Amendment
rights when they're in Russia using
Facebook that Americans are reading I
don't think so they have Russian rights
um so does the FBI have to give Russians
First Amendment rights if they're using
American corporations I don't know well
non-citizens do have constitutional
rights when they're in the country
that's right but not when they're using
technology when they're not in the
country but they're using technology see
it's a weird reality now where Tech you
can be in Russia but also be in the
United States via video chat and it
looks like you're here it sounds like
you're here
well as far as I'm concerned the FBI
stepping in and saying anything to this
so-called private company just removes
the argument that of course the
government's not the one censoring it's
just Facebook saying that you can or
can't share this this is 100 the
government deciding what people could or
should see and it's not even about
Russia at this point because I'm fully
convinced the FBI knew that this wasn't
Russian disinformation they just wanted
to wink wink nudge nudge Facebook into
being like okay so we'll keep this on
the down low mines mines frames a little
differently they say Mark Zuckerberg
tells Joe Rogan that Facebook
algorithmically censored the hunter
Biden laptop story for seven days based
on a general request from the FBI to
restrict election misinformation I think
that's a fair assessment and you need to
understand that means the government is
going to Big platforms and saying
restrict things you choose at our behest
yep we've got us there's got to be some
lawsuits or something to stop this
because you know I was reading recently
is it August 2nd state of Missouri I
think Gateway pundit I think Jim hoft
several other people are involved in
this lawsuit against a bunch of
Democrats Biden I think Biden and the
government saying that section 230 is a
law that gives special clearance to to
Big Tech to censor and and suppress
information but that is only possible
because the U.S government has given
them this special access which is a
First Amendment violation I completely
agree you've also got stories like Alex
Berenson
he uh uh I think it's confirmed now
right he reported this that the
government requested he be censored
specifically and then the Twitter the
government went to Twitter said why
aren't you censoring this guy and
they're like okay then they banned him
files a lawsuit gets his account back at
this point there is no argument the
government is actively playing a role in
censoring information they do not like I
guess that's the conversation like
we've always considered that the
government is taking information and
withholding some of it from us maybe to
protect us because we don't know what's
best for ourselves and now we're getting
more information that's readily
accessible to all of us and it's it's
it's making things spiral because people
can go search anything now we got
computers in our in our pockets so if we
want to learn about something we can and
I think this is just the the veils being
removed and people are getting so much
information that it's hard to stop it so
we're seeing these hard stops being put
in place it's like you know every one of
those cartoons where they're on a boat
and then like a hole breaks and the guy
sticks his finger in the hole and
another hole breaks and then his toes
and then his tongue and then his eye
goes in that's basically what's
happening they can't stop the flow of
information and they keep trying to and
it's just getting it's making things
crazier and it's making things worse
well even so it was the Sam Harris
problem anyway they had decided that
this is our guy he's going to Dethrone
the other guy it really was a matter of
time before this was going to come out
anyway they just needed to hold it in
place for just long enough for the their
guy to get installed and now it's coming
out and they can't stop it but nobody
cares now that it's coming out all the
implications of he was working with X Y
and Z and now we're sending money to X Y
and Z it doesn't matter anymore they won
yeah who was it who was just on who said
things gonna get crazy was it Amy Wolf I
think so oh yeah she's been saying that
she's like the election well that that
moving now into the midterms yeah we're
gonna see really crazy stuff like you
don't you don't know that was Mike
Glover Mike Glover yeah yeah he was like
it's going to get crazy as far as
Revelations no just in terms of like
like weird political stories yeah do you
have sober surprises oh yeah it's like
we're gonna see like 50 October
surprises yeah it's gonna be like you
know nudes of old people oh no it would
be like someone's gonna be accused of
literally throwing a pie at some other
guy it's gonna be great I mean look what
they did with Brett Kavanaugh right
Brett Kavanaugh was accused of like I
mean the accusations are just laughably
insane that men were lining up outside
of dorm rooms yeah and like nobody said
anything for 30 years it's just it's
just kind of crazy to do it and and
people I I you know I gotta be honest I
don't think these people really believe
it but I don't think they're they're
Lucid to have to really believe anyway I
think they're like mindlessly droning on
and just parroting where they I just
think they're broken like these people
are just broken and they've they've gone
to a point where their party keeps
moving their line and if they don't move
with it they get ousted they get taken
away from their party so you
successfully broken half of the people
and they'll just pair it whatever they
need to pair it whether they believe it
or not I've got a bunch of friends that
you know a couple years ago they had
different stances and we could have a
rational conversation walk away and
shake hands but we can't do that anymore
crazy well like the crazy thing is there
are people that I've I've known for 20
years and as soon as like you know like
the shows are getting prominence
someone I talked to regularly all of a
sudden now is running full speed to
produce Outlets being like I I'll make
whatever up you know it's just just what
do you want to hear what should I tell
you about them and they're just tweeting
things like crazy and I'm like what the
this is weird yeah what happened with
you and your friends did you notice like
a shift we lost a lot a lot of friends
man uh like like you know 10-year
friends I there's actually a couple that
still haven't reached out to us you know
and these were people who were supposed
to be like God Parents to our children
like very very close deep friends and
you know my thoughts always been
you saw me do one thing one time but
you've known me for a decade you know
where I live if you actually want to
know you can just come talk to me it's
not about you it's about people feeling
like I just need to say what they tell
me to say because I don't want trouble
so uh the example that I think really
hits the nail in the head that I've
brought up several times now Ad nauseam
is a woman asking three other women what
is a woman
and um again I think it was I should
probably check who said I think it was
Matt Walsh these young women know what a
woman is but they're trying to reconcile
that with what they're supposed to say
it is and so they end up stuttering and
stammering and making no sense because
it's like there's an obvious logic and
then there's but I'm not allowed to say
it yeah the fascist word is one of those
like I feel like everybody told me he
said I was supporting fascism by doing
this show and then the other night we
had Joe adepo on who's the Surgeon
General of Florida and I'm like how is
interviewing the Surgeon General of the
state fascism that's the most insane
accusation but like people this whole
like Trump is a fascist narrative is
like if you don't I think if you don't
fall into that then you start to get
left behind it's because he is the enemy
like we don't look at each other like
neighbors anymore we're gonna look at
each other like fellow citizens the idea
is you are either with me or you are my
enemy we don't have conversations that
that want to produce relationship
anymore we have conversation that we
only want to produce I'm right and
you're wrong and if you don't believe
what I believe then you're out you think
part of this is like from follower
counts on social media we didn't used to
have that and now everyone's kind of
competing almost I think it's a big
component of it I think that that kind
of helps bring us to where we are but
but a big component of it is just that
you can really see now who uh
10 20 years ago you know talking about
people who are friends now you know who
actually
was your friend who actually believed
what they were saying and now you can
tell who was just saying what they
thought was socially acceptable
acceptable because they wanted
they wanted something yeah maybe it's
always been this way yeah but social
media is um it's almost like a it's a
room you can go vent in and now you're
just allowed to say it and well it's not
real there but I mean it's real you have
your opinions you post them and now we
know people for who they are and it's
readily accessible one of the positive
things happened with me is my Facebook
Instagram got nuked almost immediately
so anything bad that I said over the
past 10 years like it's gone I never
said anything wrong you can't find it
let's so let's let's do this we got a
bunch of stories but let's start with
yours because
um is I mean you've done a local
interview but is this like the first big
discussion you've had about what
happened on January 6th I did a local
interview with uh with Mike Calta super
nice guy he's he's been in radio for a
long time is really nice to me and he's
like you know I'd love to have a chat
with you wasn't speaking negative or
anything so I was like yeah I'll come
talk with you and I did another one with
um with a guy who just reviews guns I'm
not gonna give him a shout out because I
don't know he's he's still building you
know but um super nice guy we just kind
of chatted about what happened so uh
you're the podium guy and this is an
egregious incorrect statement because it
was a lectern and everybody is telling
us that in the chat but uh so you know
for those aren't familiar there's this
famous photo that comes out of the
January 6 riots or whatever it's you and
you're carrying a lectern while smiling
and waving to the camera and uh
how did it all happen what's the story
behind it I mean how far do you want to
go back like why did I go I mean let's
just start with like yeah yeah sure tell
us your story man so um I wasn't really
into politics a few years ago I'm busy
raising kids changing diapers and doing
Common Core math you know and um covet
struck and I started listing because I
had more free time just trying to find a
hobby and uh you know followed the
elections and everything you know listen
to a bunch of stuff and uh I had never
voted before I voted and I voted in
2019. for the first time a registered
independent forever just didn't really
have much stake in getting out there and
doing something because my life was
pretty good you know and uh listen to
what was going on started getting some
opinion some ideas and I decided I'm
gonna go to a trump rally it's going to
be the last one you know I'd never been
to one before you know I always listen
to the guys Twitter was hilarious you
know so um I bought some tickets with a
friend of mine and we just had it up
there
and uh it was the first rally I'd been
to never been to a protest before it's
kind of a new experience for me so I
didn't really know the etiquettes of
what a protest is did you go to he was
Trump was speaking at the ellipse yes
did you go there yes that's where I was
by The Monuments and uh the World War uh
the World War II Memorial how did you go
from there to the Capitol Building over
there for um I think about a couple
hours and uh at the very end of his
speech he's like we're gonna March down
to the Capitol we're going to March
peacefully let our voices be heard you
know and we didn't really have any plans
that day you know after the facts so I
was like well I guess it's going there
so I guess we'll follow
so it's you know just following cattle
so you follow people you make it to the
Capitol Building what happens next
so when we um on the walk there we
actually there's a lot of people there I
mean I've never seen so many people
um we heard from the crowd uh Pence
didn't do it Pence didn't do it it's
over you know and at that point people
are just there the pace picks up some
people start running you know they're
funneling through the crowd and I'm like
what's going to happen you know so I
follow because I'm curious I'm there to
see what happens I'm there to witness a
little bit of history and I follow the
crowd when we get to the Capitol it's
already Under Siege you know I compare
it to like watching um uh like an ant
hill being kicked you know just just
people everywhere oh but so but but
elaborate on that did you see violence
did you see people tearing things down
oh yeah there was definitely violence
there that day and you know I I try to
be as honest as possible like people
were hitting cops as you're walking up
you're seeing all that happen yes yep
I'm filming it I'm watching it go down I
mean when I first got there they were
kind of just arguing back and forth you
know protest rhetoric you know you've
betrayed us you know defend our country
this and that and at some point just
things popped off you know one side
started pushing the other side pushed
back there was tear gas mace there was a
flashbang at a point you know but people
were hitting cops
so well so so next what's next so I
don't want to stick around that because
I don't want to be a part of that you
know I'm just kind of tacitly sitting
back there videotaping it because
holy cow what's happening in front of me
you know so the next thing uh I climb up
some scaffolding to kind of get a bird's
eye view to see what's happening
and um you can't tell whether things
start and stopped I mean it was just
funneling in for almost every street you
know kind of beholding the whole thing
and you know it's kind of like well I'm
not sure what to do next you know as I
come down the stairs from the
scaffolding I notice people are going
inside the building you know and I'm
like well I guess that's where the
protest is going I guess I'll go inside
you know so I walk through open doors
with a group of people
um I get to uh the Rotunda and when we
get there people kind of disperse
because it's such a large room you know
it's a beautiful room too so you know
whatever people were walking in with a
chance it got real quiet real quick and
people are looking around at the
paintings the statues the Oculus I mean
it's it's it's a beautiful room
and then um I kind of wander around a
little bit take some pictures and I
noticed there's uh there's this lecture
in sitting kind of like underneath some
stairs it's kind of out in the open I'm
like man that would make a great photo
you know kind of in the middle of a
rotunda I called it you know I nailed it
and um so I take the lectern out I set
it down I give a short speech and then I
go wander around a little bit more
so that was that photo of you carrying
the lectern was you you took it from
under some stairs and then and then what
you put it down somewhere I put it down
in the middle of rotunda and then you
started talking to people yeah I just I
gave a short speech it was like three
lines you know kind of a kind of LARPing
politics you know and um I left it there
I didn't put it back where I find it you
know so shame on me but um after that I
walked away um I went down um I saw
where the speaker of the house is kind
of hallway is I kind of walked down
there I saw Nancy Pelosi star I'm like
holy cow
that's where she does her stuff you know
and so um you know I I touched the
doorknob I got it I did touch the
doorknob I didn't try to open the door
it's like a Boop you know and uh but the
door was lost like all right well walk
away from that so I come back down the
hallway kind of getting bored kind of
getting lost never been to the capital
before and I see another group of people
that are uh coming in that's a whole
nother wave and they kind of seem like
they know where they're going they they
know we have a plan or whatever you know
so I follow that group and uh this group
heads down towards I think it's the
Senate chamber where they were and so I
kind of tag along with the group you
know I'm texting my wife texting my
friends and you're like oh I'm inside
you know like you should leave I'm like
ah I'll leave in a minute I'll leave him
I guess more pictures so um we get down
to the doors and uh you know they're
banging on the doors and stuff I'm kind
of just you know looking around taking
pictures I talked to a guy next to me
and I'm like what are they doing like oh
that's where they are and I was like
what do you mean that's where they are
it's like that's that's where their
meetings count the votes like they're
still here what are they doing here you
know said that but I'm like I probably
shouldn't be here you know so um I do
one around for a few more minutes uh
someone releases either tear grass gas
or uh some type of fire extinguisher and
uh you know hurts my eyes it burns
answers yeah yeah it's not comfortable
you know so um I went around a little
bit more I find a cop and ask a cop hey
man how do I get out of here I'd like to
leave now and uh the cop tells me well
you know go down the hallway take a
right there's an officer out there he's
uh taking people accident outside so
just go over there it'll be done and
that was my experience inside the
capital and so then you leave you leave
the capital and then uh you had no did
you have any idea what was about to come
in terms of the national attention the
photo no no I knew a photographer had
taken my picture because you know
professional photograph have been pretty
easy to spot you know but I didn't think
anything would come of it I thought well
I like trespass you know worst case
scenario tell me I can't come back again
but I got my photos I saw the building
I'm good you know so you thought you
were trespassing I mean
yeah yeah I mean I could admit that I
mean I did walk into a building I'm
pretty sure they didn't want me inside
of so I can say yes I did trespass so
after you leave
um what like when did you when did you
find out that it was much more serious
than you had realized so my phone had
died inside I had it charging in my
backpack on a um on a battery pack and
uh I made it outside uh got a couple hot
dogs was walking back to the hotel and
uh turned the film back on after hit
like 10 15 and my phone just started
blowing up man couldn't even use it
because there were so many messages
coming in uh eventually I put on
airplane mode so I can kind of go
through see what was going on and uh it
struck me because there were so many
people like dude you're famous there are
memes of you I was like well that didn't
go as planned you know so um before I
even made it back to my hotel I was
getting recognized on the street
when did you uh find out that you're in
serious trouble
um so I made it back to the hotel room
and it was when I started watching CNN
and CNN had told uh the people that this
is an Insurrection uh these people
should go to prison for 20 years you
know and then I found someone got shot
and I'm like oh my Lord that's that's
really really bad and things started
devolving from there
when did like when did you first make
contact with law enforcement how did it
come to be that you end up you know
facing charges well I'm friends with
quite a few Leos
um so I called a cup I'm like hey is
this going to be a big deal
and uh they did allude to they did say
like they're probably going to want to
have a conversation with you at some
point you know because what you did is
what they're saying you did and uh so I
I called a couple of friends of mine a
good buddy of mine his name is Channing
supposed to say Jennings good buddy of
mine Jennings uh he said uh he said look
I got a couple of lawyers you should
give them a call just do it ahead of
time gets get some defense set up
because things are probably not going to
be great for you and then weeks to come
so go ahead so then what happens you get
uh you get you know you called some
lawyers do they eventually uh do they
make contact with the feds or the feds
come to you or what yeah so uh my
attorney's uh David bigney and Dan
Eckhart fantastic people I highly
recommend them I'm also shout them out
um so uh I got a hold of them and
they're like listen this is going to be
a case of a lifetime you don't want to
wait you need to get us hired because
they're gonna come after you hard you
don't get to get a photo like that and
become you know Infamous overnight and
not see them come after you so um we got
the prices from and I was like oh well
I'm not going to pay that that's absurd
you know but we did you say what those
prices are um I was a hundred thousand
dollars wow yeah to hire them yeah
it's a hundred thousand dollars and uh
we were paid off now so we're fine and
God is good but um
we did end up hiring him and I I had a
flight that was supposed to leave on
Friday but I rented a car like that
night picks it up in the morning and
drove back because I knew like charges
are probably coming and I'd like to see
my family for a couple hours before they
picked me up when did the charges come
the charges came on on a Friday about
how long after I left uh Thursday
morning around six a.m in the next week
and no the next day oh the next Friday
the next day yeah within I think within
48 hours I was uh the ausa which is the
assistant United States attorney's
office was already in contact with my
attorneys and vice versa and uh they
were talking about these are the charges
we're bringing and uh he's gonna have to
go to jail until we'll figure something
out what were the what were the initial
charges that they wanted to get you on
uh it was a violent entry which is a
misdemeanor it was um entering and
remaining uh restricted building which
is a misdemeanor and then um it's
glorified trespassing and then a felony
theft for moving furniture 20 yards
you did not end up with the felony or
anything so so so how does it how does
it end up you know with your your
criminal case where are you at now uh so
again my attorneys are awesome um I'm
not a felon which is fantastic I get my
voting rights back which are very
important to me and I also get my
firearms back which are equally
important to me which is good um I did
75 days in a uh in a federal prison camp
and then I did um five thousand dollar
fine and I got 200 hours of community
service but I'm enjoying my community
service what kind of stuff are you doing
is community service I am working uh for
an organization called um adopt a cop
which was uh founded for um it was after
uh George Floyd I believe it was after
George Floyd I got to read the statement
again but uh basically training cops in
Jiu Jitsu to be able to so do suspects
in a non-lethal manner so I work with
with Law Enforcement Officers doing
training programs rolling with them I've
got a big function I'm organizing a
couple weeks I can't talk about yet but
it's it's I'm enjoying it that's awesome
yeah I'm enjoying it so so you end up in
a prison camp you said yes what what is
what what is that is that not a big you
know cell block with razor wire or what
does that mean so um I didn't know
anything about prison before this
started so my idea of prison is like
Shawshank Redemption you know and uh in
Green Mile so I was not super thrilled
about it
um they have I guess four I think it's
four different levels of prison so
there's like Max security where like the
murderers go there's a medium which is
you know not as bad you know scalable
and there's low and then there's camp
and they place you based on your charge
and there's like five different levels
of things where it's like you know or
you have gang ties you know is your is
it a violent record how many times
you've been arrested uh recidivism and
uh
or something else can't recall so it's a
camp you're like are you like outside
with like a fire roasting marshmallows
or what it's not it's not that nice
um so it's not like it's not steals not
cages you know it's like open dorms
you've seen orange as the New Black no
open dorm so you can come and go as you
please or what uh typically yeah like
they're running out of your room
obviously get out of the room yeah
there's yes I mean there's times you
have there's curfew it's got to be in uh
there's also wake-up time you have to be
up and they give you jobs to do uh in
the camp uh the prisoners to everything
they do the cooking they do the laundry
they do the lawn maintenance they do
everything they keep you busy ah so what
did you have to do I did nothing I told
them not gonna work oh really I will not
work for the government you cannot make
me so they didn't make you no so let's
let's go back to this day on January 6th
it sounds like from the story you've
told us you had you had no real idea
what was going to happen no you had no
plans nope you had no real intentions
nope I wanted to see an end of an error
it was gonna be Trump's last hurray and
I thought that would be a great thing to
witness a little bit of history and uh
you make your way into the capital kind
of just bumbling and not really
understanding what was going on around
you like a little bit like you knew
there was fighting you knew there was
trespassing but you were just kind of
like oh I left the group of people who
were fighting because that's not what I
am and that's not what I agree with so
there were a group of people that are
doing that and I said those aren't my
people so I went and I found something
else to do I think you know the reason
why I went ahead on that is obviously
the narrative is Insurrection and all
that and while I certainly think there
were people who were rioting and you
know trying to do something the reason I
don't like the phrase Insurrection is
that the idea that several hundred
people can stand in a building and
change a government is like absurd it's
not the 1600s anymore and even then it's
like that that it didn't even work for
Hitler right the the was it the uh the
beer hall push he like fires a gun in
there and declares he's taking the
government over and then you come and
arrest him like what do you think this
is uh and then he had to Hitler's rise
to power was actually through politics
because just trying to stand in the
building doesn't accomplish anything I
think that's an important distinction
with everything we're hearing
um especially with your story obviously
it doesn't speak to the people who were
fighting and you know one guy was like
brutally hitting a cop he got serious
charges and he should be in prison for
that absolutely you you like you don't
go and beat people for any reason no you
know but uh but I think the important
thing is that a lot of the people who
are there uh there's there's two things
one in your case you knew they were
fighting you knew you were trespassing
you got convicted you you you you
pleaded uh to a misdemeanor charge then
you went to prison there are some people
who watched the police open the door and
fan them in yes this guy wasn't named
Matthew Martin I think his name was that
his name
acquitted on all charges because the
judge said there's a video showing a cop
waving him in and then the cops are
saying I agree with it and then cops
taking selfies with people getting
getting to fully understand this is
extremely important if we're gonna you
know actually move forward with this
like in this country and try and solve
these problems well it's Case by case
and I think the problem with calling an
insurrectionist or call immediatives
reaction is evidence direction that says
you
your generalizing statements right it is
Case by case some people did something
some people did other things but it's a
blanket statement everything is I think
horrible like I mean so I tell people
I tell people it's kind of like looking
what happened with uh with a Summer of
Love right I'm sure there are a lot of
people that showed up to a protest that
turned into a riot you know and I can't
I support protests in all forms if
you're angry about something you don't
like how something's going go protest go
vote you're allowed to speak as I mean
currently you know but go do something
about it you know not violent don't
encourage that but I tell them you can't
just call all the black lives matter all
Riders because there are a lot of people
there that were just protesting you know
and so I won't blanket statement that at
all I won't but I want the same courtesy
also given to some of us that were there
that were just protesting but there is
still
for at these black lives matter protests
and on January 6th there are people who
I guess January 6 is a little bit
different but on for these for these
protests where black lives matter for
instance in Portland we're throwing
firebombs there were people who were
providing cover whether intentionally or
not at a certain point it's kind of like
if you're standing there and you're
watching people throw fire bombs at a
building and you're like well I'm going
to remain a part of whatever this is
like at a certain point you are playing
a role in that sure sure so I guess
maybe the same thing extends to us as
well like you know if we if we saw
things and didn't leave I mean maybe
that extends us as well well you have to
buy that logic yep I think so um and I
want to I want to draw distinction
between the people who were LED in by
cops and the people who were there
watching the fighting or fighting
themselves sure the issue with that is I
certainly don't think you you should you
deserve to be called an insurrectionist
or be charged with felonies because
other people were fighting but you were
part of a riot the police have to deal
with you as much as they have to deal
with people who are fighting but the
people who are fighting are the ones
causing them a problem and then you know
be it black lives matter at January 6
being part of this this big crowd and
coming in and coming out is straining
the resources to try and stop the
violence absolutely and I think it's a I
don't know why they're putting so many
reasons towards it I mean there's plenty
of other things that I think most people
would rather have solved than a couple
of people who are walking around taking
selfies well low hanging fruit you you
know that that photo of you is Iconic
yeah everybody's everybody's seen it and
it's you know the look on your face is
confidence so for for the left they view
you as this arrogant guy who was
engaging in this Behavior with no
remorse and on the right they they view
it as Defiance sure not to everybody but
so you know they have to strike at
symbols sure sure and I think so like it
is biphasic I mean you can feel multiple
emotions at the same time you know so
there's part of me where it's like holy
cow look where I am you know so A smile
will definitely come from that where
it's you're witnessing history and
things are going crazy so maybe it's a
nervous smile you know maybe it's
anxious but at the same time I mean
there's also fear that I'm feeling at
the same time because where is our
country going in what the heck is
happening here so uh you somehow managed
to uh you got approval to come on the
show is that what happened I did yeah um
initially it was a no I requested my PO
office it's probably gonna get me a job
well it's fine I requested my uh my PO
off us hey I'd like to go travel to do
this podcast it's you know I watch you
guys all the time I thought that'd be a
really good experience and he seemed
pretty cool with it up front and the
reason I had to ask travel is because uh
part of my restrictions uh being on uh
probation or supervised release is I
have to stay in the Middle District of
Florida I can't leave that I've been
there for the past almost two years
while I was under a pre-trial
indictment so the opportunity to travel
is like I really want to be able to do
that again so I contacted the PO it's
like it shouldn't be a problem let me
let me run it up the ladder you know and
we'll you know we'll talk about it a
couple days pass you know it's like why
don't you why don't you come in we'll
have a conversation in person
so I come in for the conversation in
person and um it's it's implied and I
don't want to throw it in the bus
because these people are doing their
jobs and we can debate that later but he
um he's like you know we got some emails
we got some information that maybe it's
not the best time you do that you know
like uh they said you know you can't
make any money right now this would you
would be profiting if you came like oh
no I'm buying my own plane ticket I'm
renting my own car and getting my own
hotel I mean I won't even eat food from
you guys because I just don't I don't
want anything you know and uh and he's
like well the timing is also bad you
know midterms are coming up you know you
got to consider your wife's job you got
to consider she may lose it if you get
in the media again you know they'll
write stories about you again and you
know the death threats will come and I'm
like all those things are still
happening you know doing this or not I
still get letters in the mail you know
threatening my family my wife still gets
reviews from patients that are not her
patients giving her one star messing
with her credibility you know and the
news is still writing stories about me
they put together a montage a couple of
weeks ago of all of all the things I did
in the capital you know so I mean
nothing's really going to change except
for maybe there'll be one extra story
this week
so it's nice to know you put it back
down
but that's the thing a lot of people
believe that you took it out you you
left with it well because people like
Jimmy Kimmel came out and said this guy
stole a lectern yeah like I how that's
interesting too because for all anyone
who knew you could have just picked it
up and put it down like which is
essentially what you did uh so they they
told you it was not a good idea or the
outright said you can't do it
um it was a no up front it was a no up
front uh we got a supervisor in the
meeting because I wasn't taking no for
an answer because it's it's a free
speech issue right I'm allowed to speak
there's nothing a political saying I
can't speak it just says I can't profit
you know for the next five years so if I
get a chance to speak I'm gonna speak
and it's not it's not about money it
isn't I mean like if they wanted a
lifetime plea deal where I couldn't make
money it's like I'm not signing a life
sentence with you people it's not going
to happen so five years seems more
adequate we got to talk down to five
years but it's not about the money it's
about being able to speak and tell
people what happened and for the life of
me we have all of these people who
weren't there telling us what happened
yeah we don't hear from people who were
actually there speaking about it and I
think we're doing a disservice to the
American people by not asking people who
actually saw things and were actually
there
so then initially it was a no but then
it turned into a yes somehow it did um I
reached out to my attorneys and uh they
are magicians within uh within an hour
of a phone call in conversation I won't
speak about who they talked to or what
they said I got an email saying
send me your travel itinerary I kind of
feel like the email was if you don't let
him speak the story will be even bigger
when you denied him the right to speak I
think it's definitely that because they
had hinted well we'll take it before the
judge you know the Pontius pilot efforts
like we're not telling you no but we're
gonna ask the judge if we can go and um
and I again I explained it to my
attorneys and he's like there's no way a
judge is going to put his name on you're
not allowed to speak you know and that's
kind of what we chatted about lo and
behold within an hour I get an email so
here you are and uh how have how have
things been since you mentioned you're
still getting death threats people are
going after your wife and things like
that what's it like I mean you're in
Florida which is good where the god king
Reigns yeah so how is it what's been
happening after you know since since
then well we live in we live in a pretty
uh red bubble are where we stay so I I
have a lot of local support like a ton
of local support do people do the wave
to you when they see you I it's constant
I have a couple it's I mean people will
take pictures with me they want to buy
me a drink or they want to buy me a
sandwich you know like oh you're a hero
you're a patron like I moved Furniture
20 yards and someone took a picture of
it you know it's crazy how that happens
though it's like you uh uh you you made
a mistake going in there obviously
obviously you did relatively little but
it's become such a powerful symbol for
both the left and the right well I think
a lot of what I hear is people say I
wish I was there with you I'm glad you
said something I'm glad you did
something you know I have people saying
like I wish you would have taken the
lectern and you know shoved it you know
somewhere to this who owns it and I'm
like well no no no no that's not good
like that's not how we win the culture
War we have that's that's not the way
forward I mean easily that that photo is
is propaganda Weaponry you know and
again like you like Jimmy kimmelson you
stole it is that what yeah Jimmy
Campbell came out and said I showed my
picture that this guy stole a Podium you
know and it was like the day after it
was a lectern and it was a lectern I
know sources buddy this is the thing I
have to talk about with the summer of
love black lives matter had net support
of like 52 it was ridiculous the overall
majority of this country was like yeah
black lives matter is good then the
riots happened and it tanked the the
support for black lives matter dropped
lower after the after the riots than it
had been in the lead-up to George
Floyd's death when George Floyd died
black lives matter supports skyrocketed
and then the riots happened and they
lost like a year of PR gains and they've
not since recovered could have become a
political party instead but it's got a
riding they should have become and now
it's now it's Rife with scandals and
weird money stories and everything they
they imploded over that stuff nothing's
gonna come with that and so so I mean
here's the it's I'll call this like a
warning as well as a as a point about
how people behave when uh I've been
reading about obviously I read about
Civil War all the time because I won't
shut up about it right
and I was I was thinking recently that
it's not a civil war because Civil War
implies two organized factions in some
capacity fighting and I would say okay
if you're talking about information
Warfare and political Civil War
definitely but if we're talking about
will this lead to states seceding and
fighting maybe but I want I said I want
to revise that because it may actually
be more revolutionary you know James
Lindsay mentioned that Warren's coming
out of Revolution you take a look at the
splitting factions within law
enforcement in the federal government
and then I started reading about uh you
know more about Weimar Germany because
I've I I've read a little bit and I've
read it before about the beer hall push
which is you know Hitler went into the
Munich Beer Hall and then like you know
fires a gun in there and it's like we're
taking over and then they come and
arrest him I think some people died and
then he goes to jail and he got like a
five-year sentence served like eight
months dictated mineconf then he gets
out and then what do they do run for
office
so I'll put it this way
that's a warning and also a point the
violence didn't work what worked is
winning hearts and minds and then going
and running in politics the scary thing
is a very awful and evil psychotic
person but used that to try and gain
power now it's a bit different with
Soviet Russia a bunch of crazy people
but that's the left the Communist stuff
they go out and get violent and then
they're allowed to do it what did James
Lindsay call it
uh something tolerance repressive
tolerance impressive tolerance sorry so
I wonder if we're heading towards uh
revolutionary period you know I mean I I
want to be as white pilled as possible
I'm watching primaries which I just
voted in my first primary ever I am no
longer a registered independent I am a
registered Republican I am proud of it
because I think that we need to make a
change I do I just voted my first
primary and I want to be white pills and
I'm watching what's happening and I
think I think it might actually work I
think we might actually be able to win
the culture I'm hoping we do my fear is
that the pendulum has already been set
in motion and it's the stuff I don't
know where the stop point is going to be
I don't you know with uh Carey Lake
winning and it was a it was a nail biter
because like the night before it looked
like she was down a little bit and
everyone was like no way and the next
day she sweeped she swept every County
and it's like okay there it is that's
what everyone expected that when she won
then Hageman won Joe Kent won and we're
seeing you know a bunch of primaries
where America First populous types are
actually winning and it's like now more
than ever is is the time to tell
everybody alike dude back away from the
violence you're winning you're winning
on these fronts Now's the Time to go out
rally friends go vote because you are
winning yeah you know a sense like it's
a global Revolution is kind of what
we're in the middle of right now it's a
conscious what I've started YouTube in
2006 my channel said a revolution of the
mind I found out years later that's what
Mao called his Cultural Revolution
and I'm glad I got away from that
leftism cult mindset because I was
really like family is whatever your
families whatever you want it to be kind
of weird you know like going that
post-modernist route
um but I definitely think because of the
internet or along with the internet
people around Earth are realizing that
they're under a boot of totalitarianism
a lot of people and they want out they
like American republicanism they love
the idea of free speech and second
amendment rights a lot of and a lot of
people are able to communicate with
through their governments without their
government intervention and are kind of
there's a desire for a new world order I
mean it's very obvious that the old
liberal economic order is is faltering
yeah but I think both factions have
their own desire for a different type of
new world order that fits their own
ideologies and I think that's where we
are right now yeah there's two there's
so many different the ideas of how it
could come there's there's three there's
a liberal International economy and
that's the powerful Elites the banking
cartels the IMF you know Swift payment
systems for international settlements
yeah then there's the left and they want
a socialist utopian Revolution worker
rights and then there's the right they
want a national uh you know re-emergence
nationalist re-emergence of sovereign
Nations that have international treaties
and ties and things like that one of
those sounds like a good time yeah I
yeah you know my attitude is like hey I
like the idea of um Global governance
via treaty meaning like no um Council of
Elites who can strip your rights from
you but um potentially a world court is
preferable to World War sure but that
would mean that within the borders of a
country that they have no Authority it
is only outside the borders between
countries where they would they would
they would intervene in any capacity I
love it it's an extension of federalism
the United States federalism it's it's
got to be I mean it makes so much sense
it sort of would adopt that the federal
government has the ability in the United
States to go to States and enforce law
I'm saying not that I'm saying there
would be no Global court that could go
into Illinois and arrest someone for an
international thing it would be it would
be up to the country to actually go and
do it but if there was an issue of like
a U.S plane flying over to another
country and then doing something that's
when a world Court would intervene and
be like we're going to stop this and not
allow it so it would only be a direct
International matters and my point there
is like for one maybe maybe you need
some thinking and maybe there's an
argument and debates to be made over it
but I'm kind of like Hey how do you stop
World War how do you stop people from
blowing each other up well I don't want
anybody coming to America and being like
you can't do this you can't do that now
we're our country we have our borders we
will function the way we deem is right
for us you go do your thing instead of
us going and bombing each other maybe
there is a mediation system in World
Court that will the one of the mediation
systems that's being pushed is um this
uh what do you call it uh social credit
score they think that if you can like
get people to self-censor and kind of
control people's money that then you
will pacify them but you know
pacification often in times means like
destruction and death of people when
they're like we're going to pacify the
population it was very nice because
pacifists don't want war but in reality
when you see what happens when someone
pacifies a country is oftentimes bombs
are being dropped the military is no
longer able to fight back kind of I
don't want that and I don't like the
social media Square stuff I don't know
but I feel like we're doing it to
ourselves with upvotes and down votes on
social media and likes and stuff yep
let's jump to the story Let's uh we'll
shift here from The Daily Mail Democrats
Civil War over student loans explodes
but in his blast it is out of touch and
told he is punishing those without a
degree by his own party as new
projections say it will cost Americans
500 billion dollars this is
um maybe a white pill moment Joe Biden
wanted to Pander to progressives the
problem is the Democratic party is split
between the establishment moderate types
and the far left Joe Biden can't win
he goes and says okay fine I'll give you
some student loan forgiveness which he
doesn't really have the author I don't
believe he's the authority to actually
do this it's a matter for Congress and
then they're trying to claim he's got an
emergency ability to do it the left says
it's not enough what is this you know
they're happy with some of it but it's
not enough the Democrats are now coming
after him being like you are giving
money to to the highest incomers in this
country it's an insult to taxpayers it's
an insult to the working class and it's
an insult to those who did not take out
loans because they receive no benefit
and the Republicans are sitting there
going uh-huh exactly so this sounds like
the Democrats are going to get crushed
come November they were looking good in
something in that New York 19 special
election then Biden comes out and does
this the left they don't like Joe Biden
leftists do not like Joe Biden he's not
going to win them over all he's doing is
pissing off the swing districts that to
me is crazy but it sounds like
the way things are gone
Republicans I don't like how they
phrased this article here Democrats
Civil War I don't like that they're
softening that term Civil War I feel
like we're doing a real disservice to
our species if we do that because Civil
War is not a good thing even in metaphor
well they're just conditioning to hear
their word civil more and more so when
it starts happening you know it's like
oh it's been around for a while we've
been in it for a little bit you know
secondly I just posted on Twitter
earlier I'm having issues with this loan
repayment thing because I have I'm in
this bracket under a hundred thousand
dollar salary it's like hundred thousand
dollar salary uh 25 000 in student loans
probably eight thousand of it or ten
thousand of it is interest unpaid that's
accrued over the last 20 years I'm not
comfortable taking this money if they're
going to print it from the federal I'm
not I will not take this money if they
print it from the Federal Reserve I
don't know do you have to apply for it I
don't know there's a website I heard
that's already down yeah that's right
I'm not going to do this to my fellow
Americans man they do not deserve to pay
my bill that's insane this is the
craziest thing too it's like um a bunch
of conservatives or are coming out
saying like this is wrong student
student debt forgiveness is wrong and
then the left is responding by showing
screenshots of them having accepted PPP
loans I think it's weird that they took
PPP loans I gotta be honest yeah I know
there was a reason to do it there was
Market stagnation and you know people
don't want to go under but I kind of
look at some of these companies and I'm
like these companies make a lot of money
did they really need it because I'll
tell you this timcast did not either
yeah daily wire didn't do it they did
not no in fact they were circulating a
screenshot of a guy named Ben Shapiro
far and wide saying look at this the
daily wire took PPP funds they never did
the daily wire made a point of never
taking any PPP loans in fact if you like
look at the full screenshot of this Ben
Shapiro he's actually a real estate
agent so like no I didn't do that he's a
real estate agent yeah exactly it's like
they're just lying they're lying Tim
cast uh I will say this I
outright was like no way I'm not going
anywhere near that you know why because
I knew it's like for one it's it's all
publicly available information and I'm
like I don't want that money I don't
need that money I would rather take the
hit and then dip into the red and have
to go into our rainy day funds or
whatever then accept you know these PPP
loans or whatever it's because they're
printing it they're they're devaluing
our currency by doing if they were like
going to the the loan companies and
saying okay you're not getting your
usurious interest back because it was
unethical in the first place that I'd be
fine with then I'm like yeah let's erase
what they think they deserve but I'm not
gonna tax the the citizens by printing
more that's crazy intuition's just gonna
go up more yeah there's a meme where
it's uh it's it's that Meme of the guy
and he's like looking all happy and it
says when they forgive 10K in student
loan debt and the next one is him
looking shocked and it says when
intuition goes up 10K next year dude if
you know so Biden apparently is saying
like we got to make sure they can't
raise tuition but you can't like what
can you really do and if you're if if
I'm a business
and I sell you know I don't know with
UFOs or whatever and the guy oh no how
about this I have a business we sell
memberships over at timcast.com sign up
today if the government came out and
said they were going they're going to
cover ten dollars of everyone's
memberships if they had one I'd be like
oh it's 20 now of course that's what
happened I mean honestly I wouldn't do
that but that's kind of the idea of any
business they'd be like okay
because for the average person they're
not getting hurt because the
government's subsidizing it it is
hurting everybody because it's stripping
money from everybody to pay for a few
yeah and there's also an argument I mean
what about the people already paid off
their student loans we have uh we have a
hundred and seventy thousand dollars
left from my life students loans and
we've been paying on now for uh 12 years
you know and even if the money were
offered to us we're not in the bracket
or whatever but even the money we're
offered to us like I wouldn't take it
because I know words I know where it's
going to be paid from and we keep
bankrupting we have kids I'm I don't
want to leave my kids more debt than
what we started with yeah and it's not
gonna be the last time they do this so
is it is it a one-time thing how many
times are you gonna forgive ten thousand
dollars they also money they did this
thing where there's a there's like a 10
cap and they're getting there this is a
major move towards outright free free
college what they're saying is already I
think after 20 years the loans dissolve
and are forgiven or something like that
and then they're saying there's a Max
cap of like 10 of your income can be
paid towards it now they've reduced it
to five percent I could be getting that
wrong at something like that it's on
it's on their website and so already
they're basically eliminating people's
student loan loan debt look
on paper I'm totally in favor of debt
forgiveness and um I just think that if
you're going to go for student loans
let's start with mortgages too let's
like let's let's let's you know
alleviate debt for a lot of people trade
school trade school whatever your debt
may be and um here's my here's why I see
it
all right you want to give everybody 10K
for their student loans everyone else
gets a 10K tax credit everyone yeah ever
you can't discriminate for this but I
will say the way they're going about it
is wrong what I would say is interest
payments should be forgiven because
interest is where it's like people pay
people someone takes out a fifty
thousand dollar loan and then Ten Years
Later they're like I've paid seventy
thousand dollars back in oh Thirty and
it's like what like how does that make
sense you're you've given way more than
inflation and principle I think people
have to pay back their principles you
don't get free money there should be
some interest for inflation but not this
insane compounding BS and uh that's a
place to start however the real place
you start is ending the loan system just
shutting it down none of that but I
don't know I I I I do want to say the
main point of this is not to talk about
student loans we talk about Republicans
winning in November because if
everyone's getting pissed off about this
well how much of this is just a bribe
too like ten thousand not the fifty
thousand they promised maybe it's just
like a well we gotta do something how
much of it is just to bribe for voters
well if he was smart Biden he'd say
we're gonna give out I'm gonna sign an
order ten thousand dollars and then you
know when when next Congress you know
we're going to come together and and and
figure out how to do 50. if the
Democrats win and then people are going
to be like there's the bribe and that's
like that's the smart way to go about
doing it maybe he'll come out and say it
and say I know people are unhappy thing
10 wasn't enough in the next session of
Congress they can approve more or some
like that that's where as the dealer you
give them a little taste
get them all excited and then say you
want more now you got to pay and that
would be in the form of hey vote for us
so there's that famous quote by that
dude I can't remember his last name is
like tocqueville or something and he
said the American Republic will persist
until Congress learns that it can bribe
the American people with their own money
yep yep and that's where we're headed
dare we say Biden is maybe revealing a
pattern
one might even think he might not be a
great father or grandfather maybe he
tries to solve problems by throwing
money over the line over I'm I'm basing
this on nothing I just get the feeling
I'm looking at the the fruit of the tree
his kids turned out fine yeah yeah you
know I I just I see a pattern maybe if
we connect some dots I don't know I
don't know that's illegal I think I
think questioning uh Joe uh Joe Biden's
parental abilities is is a step over the
line George and um we here at timcast do
not tolerate the best marching of such
an honorable man perhaps he should throw
me some money too no I'm just kidding
but no I mean really this does so this
does frighten me as a person who's just
watching if if their solution and I'll
throw this at the whole Democrat Party
whatever if your solution is to throw
money at a problem instead of looking at
the root of the problem and trying to
solve
for instance a lot of people are
accepted into college who may be
I dare to say this they don't belong
there and they there's this whole
industry of just putting butts in seats
because it makes the colleges look like
there's they're this exploding business
there's lots of people going to school
you get a lot of crap degrees that mean
basically nothing flooding the market
with people a labor force who really
don't deserve to have these degrees I
dare to say so they just kind of fail
their way through college they accept
loans from whatever people are going to
give you I don't know I'm gonna give you
a loan and you're going to pay me this
much an interest in a few years they
can't pay it because they can't find
work
inflation's happening so now those loans
are basically I don't know what's
happening to the value of the loan but
you still have to pay the interest we
the taxpayers are going to be left with
the bill anyway maybe that was the plan
for the beginning but there's this this
fake industry of uh I'm a College
Dropout so I'm biased but I don't
believe in this idea of I own a piece of
paper that says I'm qualified therefore
you should hire me as opposed to I'm
just a hard-working person hey maybe
Apprentice me hire me for a few years
and then I'll be qualified it's not even
that I mean look man if uh I I said we
need to commission some art
and then you know uh Adam comes over
here and he says I have an art degree
I'd be like that's great
yeah where's the art and you bet well I
don't have any but I have a degree that
that shows you that I know how to do it
and then you know George comes over here
he's like here's a picture of my art who
am I going to hire
the artist the guy who has a picture I'm
like I like how that looks he's making
one of those not the guy who's got a
piece of paper and a degree and who paid
tens of thousands of dollars to have
that piece of paper which doesn't
necessarily prove that you're able to do
any of this stuff which is I think we're
being sold our generation especially was
sold this idea of you have to go to
college in order to get a job yes
absolutely but employers were convinced
that there was value to that piece of
paper leaving people like I'm sorry I'm
a little bitter about it leaving people
like me who I think you know I was very
hard working and stuff and I really
wanted to do what I did you know comics
and stuff but I don't think a lot of
places even considered me
um when I was you know sending my CV to
people they didn't even consider me as a
candidate
that's also made a high school diploma
worthless yeah so a lot of kids are you
know they're pretty much decided by
ninth or tenth grade they're going to
college or not you know they kind of
check I mean I know I was that way when
I grew up um I was in high school didn't
really have a lot of interest in going
to college so I kind of just played
video games and hung out you know and
now having kids you know there's that
social pressure was like I have to go to
college because I want my kids to go to
college and I know it's just it's social
engineering and I'm I'm supposed to want
to do that because good fathers do that
they make sure their sons have good
degrees and they can take care of their
kids yeah I I have to agree with George
I think that this is fully systemic and
I think it stems from the problem of
encouraging kids I think the reason we
have so much under underwater basket
weaving and so much student loan debt
right now is because kids have been told
that college is the only way to go this
is what you're supposed to do exactly
exactly and they're told this is the way
you're supposed to earn money and for a
certain time so people people got their
connection backwards it's a little bit
like the self-esteem issue that I talk
about sometimes they they thought that
people who got college degrees earned
more money because they were more
committed to their job because their
degree it was like a Big Blob it was
very important that all these things
went together the fact of the matter was
that the people who were super committed
would be the ones who would end up going
to college for that specialty and then
who would end end up going into that
profession and being really focused and
really talented what they were doing
well High School doesn't really
specialize here or set you up to go into
college right you know so too and trains
you to go to college it trains you to go
to teaches you how to school right but
anyone who's got an associate's degree
will tell you the first two years of
college or the last two years of high
school you know but again the high
school diploma is meaningless now so
maybe a solution is to make High School
meaningful these kids after 9th or tenth
grade could be taking a two-year
apprenticeship program and be coming out
as a plumber's Assistance or an
electrician assistant we can we can make
meaningful uh Solutions with public high
school 100 I just don't see that I don't
see the desire for them to do that
because they want you to go to college
no and the scary thing is that I see
this pattern for the past few years but
it's been happening for a long time of
borrowing from the future so we can pay
the bills of today our kids are going to
inherit this I don't even know what to
call it someone's going to pay this bill
it's it's maybe going to be us in 10 20
years I don't know maybe they're going
to try to sell Alaska to somebody or
something but where is this money going
to come from well they could just print
more have we tried that no we haven't
you're right just print more let's let's
do that yeah no no it wasn't 100 years
wasn't it March of 2020 that fractional
Reserve banking ended and it went
infinite Reserve yeah you can print they
can print as much as they want now
that's fine so we go wrong it used to be
that's fantastic you could you could
issue a loan creating money
up to was it 90 of your holding yeah and
then yeah the way it would work is like
I put a hundred dollars in Bank of Ian
Ian then issues a loan for ninety
dollars to George but he still has the
hundred the ninety dollars is created
upon issuance of the loan then George
gives me the 90 and then I create you
know well George then can take that 90
that so Tim you give me a hundred I have
100 I can give you 90. I keep my Hundred
you take you keep your 90 but you can
loan out 81 to someone else they can
keep their 81 but they can loan out 70.
exactly he then deposits in another bank
and then sends you another loan but no
it's crazy scheme it's crazier than that
in March of 2020 they basically said you
don't need reserves anymore I can loan I
can loan you 10 million you can loan 10
million of that I wonder if you can loan
11 million of your 10 million Banks can
just literally snap their fingers and
write money on anybody it's a game of
hot potato someone's going to be left
holding it or musical chairs or whatever
it's it's sort of but it's a game of hot
potato that like while the Hot Potato
game is playing someone is take like
they're they're juggling a bunch of
potatoes and and then the rich people
are like chucking the potatoes into a
box behind them when no one's looking
and then they're like okay guys I'm
leaving you keep playing the game I
don't and then they walk away with the
box full of potatoes yeah it's gonna be
a silly poorest that end up paying again
I mean I I definitely think it's going
to go down to a two-class system and
middle class continues to shrink and I
think what they're afraid of is
generational wealth right it's very
difficult to amass generational wealth
to set yourself up and I think the
problem is with generous wealth is that
you eventually start gaining power and
influence and the less people that can
have power and influence the less we can
change the system
I just saw that PayPal is changing their
terms of service so that soon like
within a month you're not going to be
able to send money to an offshore uh
business and an offshore business is not
going to be able to send money to your
personal PayPal account so that makes me
think that they're trying to stop people
from using offshore Banks yeah I got a
notification on uh some one of my things
of they're trying to do anti-money
laundering stuff they're really pushing
this which I think is the funniest thing
in the world because they're allowed to
money launder
the Swiss bank for international Swedish
the Swiss bank for international
settlement you wanna know what I think I
think I think Davos group I think the
world economic Forum they want crypto
like a new world currency well it's it's
Bitcoin is fully trackable and uh with
with the right AI you can see who is
doing what where when and how and you
can even infer as to why and uh they're
they're all big fans of it a lot of
these Global Elites I mean BlackRock
didn't they just buy a bunch of Bitcoin
I don't know I was gonna say I read an
article by reading an article and I read
a headline that said yeah yeah that
black Croc had bought into crypto these
institutions keep coming out and they
say things like don't don't buy crypto
and then people panic and they sell it
all to them to these institutions there
are hedge funds also that um a couple of
my Reddit last year that were actually
telling people with bigger portfolios to
make sure you start buying crypto now
yep you know there's a couple of big
hedge funds uh that's just about 2019
BlackRock this is from Investopedia
BlackRock rips Bitcoin uh colon buy
crypto only if you're ready for complete
losses which is the quote and then from
two weeks ago BlackRock announces new
Bitcoin trust
that's the game they want you to sell it
at dirt so they can buy it up now I'm
not telling you what to buy I'm just
telling you I've got crypto and I ain't
selling it I'm holding on to it because
um
it's got its function it's got a
purposes I have a couple different ones
but I I think it's gonna um I don't have
Bitcoin because I think it's gonna be
worth millions of dollars I do think
it's worth millions of dollars I have it
because I think it's going to become a
principal utility in the future it's
going to become substantially more
widespread in use and I think the the
global Elites are very very interested
in trackable digital currencies
absolutely yeah
let's jump to this next story and uh
this one's this one's interesting this
one's very interesting yeah from
Politico Trump White House exerted
pressure on FDA for covid-19 emergency
use authorizations house report fines
the report by house Democrats examining
the pandemic says Trump officials sought
vaccine approvals to sway voters before
the 2020 election uh isn't that a good
thing is that is that is that I don't
understand they're they're starting to
attack Trump because he got the vaccines
out that was like the good thing Trump
did I can't believe Trump did this to us
you know what um I'm changing my opinion
on him right now yeah here we go last
night we had James Lindsay on and on the
after show we talked about the alien
dialectic and I was like what's a
dialectic a dialectic is when you create
an opposition to what you're doing so
that you can create a conflict which
will get a new thing that you want yeah
so this is this now they're creating a
dialectic now they're now what they're
expecting is information can be come out
oh I got damaged by the back all
vaccines hurt me oh vac now they're
trying to be like okay here's the gonna
come the thing to be a push against this
Trump so that we're going to get our
outcome maybe maybe I don't I don't know
I do know and James I was like how do
you stop that from how do you defeat the
dialectic he's like well you expose it
it's like a magic trick if you show
people how to do the magic trick before
you show them the trick but but but hold
on I don't know if I agree with that
um I know there's a lot of people that
are not fans of the vaccine Trump got
booed himself YouTube recently removed
the rule and I don't know when but
probably in the past couple of weeks it
used to be that YouTube said you could
not not make claims saying that uh how
do I phrase this you you could not issue
claims that the that the vaccine did not
prevent or play a role in the prevention
of covert like there's a very weird
legal language that's gone now now you
can't claim that the vaccine doesn't
prevent serious illness or death it's
like it's weirdly phrased but basically
you can now claim I guess on YouTube the
vaccine does not stop the infection of
covet or something like that the rules
have changed here's the crazy thing
YouTube's rules used to say that you
couldn't claim masks cause brain damage
they removed that really I mean that's
where like what like what like I don't
think it does but you're allowed to
claim it and it stops oxygen that was
actually one of the rules the rule used
to be that you couldn't claim masks
reduced your oxygen level now you can
they removed that rule against it they
also removed the rule they said you
could not claim masks cause lung cancer
they removed that rule wow that's weird
yeah I'm sorry I just gotta say I'm not
a doctor or anything but I'm pretty sure
masks don't cause lungs I don't think so
yeah I mean I see a lot of people
wearing masks alone in a car and I could
see a correlate of brain damage with
that I see what you're saying but look
look you know here's what a correlation
is not causation that's right here's
what I want to say about all of this
YouTube clearly has no idea what they're
talking about and like I don't think I
think everybody should be very careful
about talking to politicians and pundits
about their health care I think fauci
yeah he was a doctor 30 years ago he's a
doctor by by title now I wouldn't take
advice from TV doctors like fauci from
politicians
find a medical professional you trust
and I and I always bring this up because
people are like oh but doctors are wrong
or bad and it's like bro Joe Rogan had a
doctor
I had a doctor like they did not you
know take the route you assumed then
every doctor will take for you but just
make sure you trust the person you're
talking about multiple doctors you don't
just go to the doctor because that's the
doctor you gotta like seek people out
look for intelligence listen to people
and listen to many many people if you
went to a doctor and you were like Doc I
got a I got a bum knee and you went well
time to amputate you'd be like no I'm
gonna leave but but here's what I want
to get to you mentioned that the
hegelian dialectic like maybe they're
now teeing it up for people to make
claims about vaccines causing injuries
and things like that not so fast Nate
Silva responded with liberal Elites
pressured Pfizer to delay vaccine until
after the 2020 election so interesting
too this is really weird Okay I I like
to pride myself on you know why would
someone say a thing and then you know I
have a thought or an idea not always
right but I'm like here's my here's what
I think I have no idea what they're
doing Nate silver coming out smearing
liberal Elites saying they pressured
Pfizer to delay the vaccine until after
the election like that's really really
bad for them
Democrats came out and said Trump was
trying to rush the vaccine before the
election
I don't know where this is going I I
heard a theory I don't remember where I
heard this from so you guys are welcome
to correct me in the chat and then you
add him sorry I just got to squeeze this
in there because I heard a theory that
they're starting to realize that things
are going to start coming out people are
going to start filing lawsuits maybe
against Pfizer I don't even know how
that works and what they're trying to
get ahead of it but I'm addressing that
this is the opposite of that Nate silver
is coming out and attacking liberal
Elites for delaying the vaccine he's
saying it's their fault but it's an
inversion it's the Democrats tried
stopping the vaccine they're bad guys
last night when we're talking about it
we're like obviously there's a lot of
stories and claims about vaccine
injuries here's my here's my view on
this
we had on the Surgeon General from
Florida
and even he you know I don't want to put
words in his mouth but the idea seems to
be look man if you give 200 million
people four shots like there's a
propensity for injury these things do
happen and we need to be careful that
we're not looking at a scale issue as
opposed to a frequency issue is it an
issue that you know X causes y amount of
injuries or is it X you know causes like
is an issue that you have a million
people one percent seems like a lot as
opposed to one percent of 100 seems like
very very little that's why I'm just
like I'm not gonna pretend to be an
expert on this one and I really want to
avoid the partisanship my whole point
here is last night
in the member section we were talking
about how
they're starting to turn on the vaccine
like this is this is this is the
narrative now all of a sudden they're
like it's a bad thing Trump got it out
and I saw that and and we talked about
it like if they start turning on it in
the next couple of years they're going
to say it's all Trump's fault but then
Nate silver comes out what is it this is
this is today yeah and he's saying
liberal Elites tried blocking the
vaccine
it's very simple when the narrative
starts changing all you have to do is
share that gif of or GIF of Stephen
Colbert dancing with the vaccines oh
yeah that's all you have to do no don't
you I remember but that's why I'm not
convinced it's changing I don't know why
the Democrats issued this report if Nate
silver is going to come out you know on
TV or something and then actually use
that against Democrats that's gonna that
that's gonna help swing States vote
Republican or swing districts this is
also assuming that liberal Elites are
Democrats they might not even be
American
well he's talking about Democrats
because they issued this report where
they're going after Trump but my point
is you're a swing District right these
are not die hard trumpers we go down to
Loudoun County for instance and there's
a lot of people who are like leaning
conservative but they don't like Trump
they don't like Maga and stuff like that
Democrats are trying to bank on that and
get those voters if Nate silver is
coming out now and saying this and using
their own report against them those
moderate right-wing individuals are
going to be they like the vaccine
they're going to be mad at democrats for
I mean this is this is a weapon for
republicans in swing districts to come
out and be like Democrats delayed this
they made the pandemic worse that's
basically what Nate silver is saying I
would think like so even fellow to
retire and there are a lot of things
related to this I think the ship is
sinking I I Lydia's point was the point
I was going to make as I think a lot of
things are sinking and falling apart and
someone's going to be left holding the
bag and at this point I think people are
like it wasn't me though I was not on
that ship I didn't agree with that look
at look at this right here quote Trump
pushed for the vaccine approvals to too
fast is the worst possible critique of
the Trump administration's covet policy
silver founder of 538 tweeted he then
said that probably saved a lot of lives
if anything approval should have been
faster in a subsequent tweet he wrote
liberal Public Health Elites pushed
Pfizer to change its original protocols
that govern its authorization of
vaccines so that the decision would be
put off until after election day two
years ago
that is a brutal condemnation of the
democratic establishment that they would
let you die to beat Donald Trump Nate
silver is tweeting that out
does that surprise anyone though what
surprises me is that the Democrats came
out with a report claiming Donald Trump
was rushing unproved treatments and the
vaccine as if it was a negative
instantly having that weaponized against
them to show that Democrats were willing
to let people die during a pandemic
because they hated Trump that much this
is I don't this is weird I always saw
what happened with coma New York
no man I won't dive too deep in that but
Gretchen Whitmer Gretchen Whitmer do
something yeah yeah I mean Dr Dr Levine
yeah Dr Levine yep always has been like
they don't care about you and I think
it's it's like going after uh it's an
abusive relationship right it's the uh
it's the I deserve to be hit you know
like that's how these people are living
they're broken they think they deserve
whatever it is they're getting and you
know it's gonna get better one day if I
just keep coming home and you know
dinner will be better next time
mandatory basic training for all
Americans at age 18 done they go well
like exercise
yeah we gotta fix their diet too yeah
make sure you guys know what basic
training is right no let's talk about
military yeah like boot camp yeah I was
kidding though but you know what I mean
well I am afraid that's all I know how
many vaccines should I have now probably
eight uh I'm actually double vaccinated
I think the currency I think the
schedule is 14 or something I think it's
no I think it's cool I think it's five
for coven now five five total vaccines I
could be wrong because it's two for the
initial and then they've got three
boosters now I think I know there were
two boosters and I think I think they
came out a couple weeks ago and asked
for a third one yeah I think the new one
is because because of the it's for uh
Omicron or no no no it's the new variant
is something else
it's actually called ligma oh no okay
thank you
yeah
I like how you pointed out that they
don't care you say like the leadership
doesn't care about you or me it's and I
kind of believe that because they don't
know who you are they and they're just
looking at spreadsheets of numbers I
have 750 000 constituents
26 of 26 000 have cancer
1700 170 000 are OB and they got these
numbers and they're trying to like move
puzzle pieces around if I do a vaccine
that prevents 36 and I do it to this
percentage of the popular they have no
and that's not how medicine functions
realistically that's why they're looking
at 3D printing medicine individually
tailored to the individual I think
that's the future of Medical Practice in
a lot we we were talking about the other
day how
it wasn't until like 1993 clinical
trials had to include females separate
yeah so it used to be that they would
take uh men give them a drug see what
happened and then said There You Go
women by body weight and then eventually
people were like hey you know like women
have different hormones and different
body structures and these drugs aren't
working the same way so we started to
discover that painkillers for instance
weren't working on women they would you
know the painkillers we would give to
men would work they'd give the same ones
to women and women complain and the
doctors would be like they're just whiny
women you know and in reality it's like
hey wait a minute
yeah so then I think it was in 1993 they
were like we need to have separate
clinical trials for male and female and
that's kind of amazing and now that's
probably going to go away because of
weird yeah how do they know they're a
female though yeah exactly well uh
actually we have a a story addressing
that check this out oh cool this is from
NBC News gender dysphoria is now covered
by disability law federal court rules
the ruling could become a powerful tool
to challenge legislation restricting
access to Medical Care and other
accommodations for Trans people
Advocates say and this uh this pertains
to the fourth Circuit Court which is
Maryland North Carolina South Carolina
Virginia and West Virginia but will
inevitably be cited in cases in other
states now
obviously this will go to the Supreme
Court it's going to be appealed the
story has to do with um prison inmates
uh I believe this was a transgender here
we go they say the decision came in the
case of a transgender woman who sued the
Fairfax County sheriff in Virginia for
housing her in a jail with men the
decision is not limited to transgender
people challenging jail policies but
also applies broadly to all areas of
society covered by disability rights law
including employment government benefits
and services and public accommodations
the decision destigmatized a health
condition gender dysphoria and it says
that what Congress did in 1990 wasn't
okay
now I can't see this standing
um because your mental state is not a
feature a a
um it's not uh you used in terms of your
physical state so if you are um
if if you are suffering depression
they're not going to be like you can't
go to this facility right if you are
having a mental issue of some sort or I
guess I look with all due respect
they're calling it a disability it's
protect Under Disability law
your mental state doesn't determine
whether or not you go to one facility or
another in many circumstances so this is
interesting I suppose you could argue if
someone's mental state was lunacy
psychosis you would go to a care
facility or Hospital instead of a prison
many people don't they just go to prison
many people are clearly unwell deranged
depressed or insane and they don't send
them to hospitals
why would it be now that someone with a
A you know a mental issue
they could use that to actually affirm
that mental issue and be transferred to
a separate facility you see where I'm
going with this like
I feel like if this did stand you would
have like jails that were strictly for
depressed people because your mental
state is not something that is a fixed
feature of your attribute like it
doesn't stay the same from day to day
and I wonder if they're trying to push
us toward the slippery slope of you know
your external genitalias not necessarily
consistent with who you really are
inside so I feel like it's just opening
or setting a really bad press and I do
hope it's challenged I hope it's not
over all together well like here's a
question if I have um what is it called
General body dysmorphic disorder
will they affirm that by amputating
amputating your body well so look for
um for people who are trans
gender affirming surgery as it's called
would be the Reconstruction uh removal
of your reproductive organs and then the
the Cosmetic alteration of them
because you are depressed by it there's
a a a another
um I think it's in the DSM-5 why don't
you call it disorder that is um body
dysmorphic disorder I think you want to
look that up because I'm looking at the
DSM-5 what aspect of it body dysmorphic
disorder can you Google that yeah I'll
check it out uh I think that's what it's
called I could be wrong that sounds
right but there are people who like mine
that is what it's called yeah like my
hand it's not my hand I I I'm like I
need it removed I mean a doctor is not
going to cut your hand off this is so
interesting to me because most people
don't know this about JK Rowling but she
under a pseudonym wrote an entire she
wrote like a series about a veteran who
had lost you know the lower half of his
leg in the war and he came back to
England and he was dealing with murder
Psychopaths who wanted who had body
dysmorphic disorder and who wanted to
like amputate their hands and whatnot
and he was incensed by this obviously
because he had involuntary amputation he
lost a leg in an IED explosion or
whatever so I I wonder if that's that's
a little bit off topic but I wonder if
that's contributed to their view of her
as a Turf because she's been like no if
you want to amputate something that's
not necessarily just something we should
accept I I have no issue with disability
law covering this I get it make sense
the DSM-5 listed as a disorder whatever
that's the opinion of the medical
experts and so if someone has
experiencing experiencing this then I
don't know if that does does disability
law give you guaranteed access to
government-funded jobs that's what I
feel like this might be aiming at is
it's a funding mechanism yeah but but
think about any other uh like I I really
I think dysmorphic body dysmorphic
disorder is the the best analogy because
we are not granting those protections to
these people
if if we're going to allow individuals
to undergo cosmetic surgery and the
removal of organs due to a a disability
would that not apply to any other uh
disorder
it would and so I would I would say that
are the prisons now going to have to
amputate the arms of individuals who are
request it
well I would imagine yes are you are you
saying that it's because it will be
doing harm
I mean it's it's a question of
I would say partially but it's a
question of does the state have to pay
for it
right sure I mean I think there's I
think the initial argument for me is is
it is it the right thing to do like is
what you're doing actually providing a
benefit
I I guess the the main issue is are
there any other circumstances where you
would be housed in a different facility
based on your mental state like if
you're supposed to go to a super max
prison
and uh you said but I'm depressed by
that
I want to go to a low security prison or
prison camp would they go well we have
to depression is a disability
I'm pretty sure depression is a
disability
right I'm not sure look that up I don't
know I'm looking at it now I want to I
want to say yes I want to say depression
assistant depressive disorder depressive
disorders yeah so what if you said um I
get anxiety attacks bereavement
exclusion bereavement is excluded from
the bereavement bereavement's like I'm
sad about what happened to me kind of
thing what if you said super max
facilities make me depressed and give me
anxiety attacks I think that's a form of
grief but I could be wrong you could
argue it's bereavement well so like
you're saying this is a step on the road
well how is how is then putting a trans
person in their biological biological
sex prison not grief right their their
ruling that if you're male but identify
as female you must be placed in the
female prison because of your mental
state well your grief would be over as
soon as you're let out because then
you're no longer in prison right you be
grieving because you're in prison you're
right so they can't lock you up that's
right wow actually I think no no grief
is not a disorder oh okay right right
but the point is if
so so look what they're saying here is
that if your biological biologically
male identifies a woman and go to a male
prison that's a disability
discrimination that's what they're
saying that's what this article is
saying if I have persistent depressive
disorder caused by being in prison it's
causing me a disability that's an that's
a violation of my rights as a disabled
person right
I should be moved to a different
facility to account to be accommodated
for this
it's really funny how prisoners uh well
we're talking about prisoners rights you
you're here maybe you can tell me about
this a little bit you've spent 70. you
have none you have none you have some
but they want them but then I'm thinking
about like the horror of war and like
War prisoners and like
we're in such a luxurious time in
history that we're able to kind of
demand how we want to be treated in
prison uh interesting yeah
it's funny right you can make all the
demands you want I mean they're they're
not going to help you their job is not
to help you like I mean so I didn't
really have an opinion on Prison ahead
of time you know but being there I
definitely have an opinion now my
thought was always you know well you did
something wrong so enjoy prison you know
but I don't think we should make it
something you enjoy though because the
idea should be you don't want to come
back here so making people comfortable
and stuff I mean it should be
uncomfortable but the psychological side
of what they do to you is horrible I
think it should be
rehabilitative rehabilitative is that
the word rehabilitative the goal should
be to rehabilitate people yeah it should
so I I read these stories about they put
people on an island in Scandinavian
countries or whatever like if you're a
super max they put you on an island and
it actually had the most successful rate
of reducing recidivism and like
reforming people because you made them
responsible for their safety security
and survival more so than if they were
in society
Australia I mean they're doing great I
mean they were yeah they're a very
successful penal colony yeah and a
continent yeah did you ever get the vibe
of isolation while you were was it
isolated because yeah so when you come
in if you're unvaccinated uh they have
to put you in uh either the shoe which
is a special housing unit and I think at
one point it was like 21 days and then
they dropped it down to five days when I
got there the issue is uh the unit they
put me in every time someone new came in
and reset the count
so when I first got there it was me and
some older guy and we you know we
chatted for a little bit but I mean I'm
just trying to keep to myself because
all I know of prison is Shawshank
Redemption and Green Mile so
um you know uh we kept having more and
more guys come in so the unit got more
and more crowded we're sharing a little
less less showers only half the toilets
work it gets uncomfortable uh we ended
up doing uh I think 17 days before they
actually put us in the other units that
was basically General housing but I
can't complain because
back when it used to be
um two weeks it was two weeks or 21 days
they had actually entire unit and there
I think there's I think there's probably
about 100 beds in there bunk beds so
they can house about 200 people per
block they got to I think it was 95
people at one point and uh they had them
housed in there for over 80 days and you
cannot leave that unit like you are
stuck there they bring you sandwiches
and you can't leave what were most
people in for
um it was kind of all over the place so
in a camp the only reason you can't be
in a camp is if you're a um it can't be
like a violent crime and you can't be a
chomo
so um what's that a trauma with a child
molester okay you can't be that so
um which is a violent crime which which
is a violent crime yeah that and also
it's it's also for their safety so um
most of the dromos are put into uh low
facilities I know the one I was at I
think the population was something like
80 to 90 percent all child molesters
which is no it's staggering but I mean
they have their own gang and stuff there
you know like you don't they protect
each other and now for everybody else
what is like Financial crimes or what
Financial crimes you know a lot a lot of
people um you know Shady business
dealings and things like that a couple
people I mean I learned about a ghost
money and ghost drugs so this is um
let's say you have a large company right
and everything I say came from came from
criminals so grain assault you know
everyone's innocent president
um so let's say you have a company and
you have someone that uh you know like
they they do your business dealings you
know because you've grown so much you
send someone they have an illegal
conversation about possibly doing
something right or let's say
um you're having a conversation about
about buying drugs but there are no
drugs you know it's not actually
happened yet if two people come together
and say he had the intention of doing
this that's a charge really that is a
charge they call it um
oh conspiracy to commit either fraud or
conspiracy to do something wow so if two
two inmates you're saying two inmates
tell a guard that a third inmate is
doing something this is in the Free
World this is this is out of prison so
the people that were there right A lot
of them are like a conspiracy male fraud
conspiracy to to do you know regular
fraud and stuff I mean I was I wasn't
there long enough to get full details of
everything was a pretty short stint but
if two people say this guy had an
attention to to buy to buy drugs or have
a shady dealing and there's CIS for the
federal government they can arrest you
on conspiracy yep so you'll get you
could be some dumb dude who's sitting
playing video games and drinking a beer
and then some guy goes hey man you know
we should do we should do this that or
otherwise right you want to do it and
then you could be like oh yeah I guess I
don't know whatever I'm like boom got
you yep and then I'll send something
you're doing you're like what like what
are you talking about I was just
watching friends reruns okay so when
someone asks you to commit a crime you
say no every time yeah but what if you
don't know
if you don't know if it's illegal yeah
take a look at marijuana laws across the
country they vary all over a lot of
people don't realize that like for
instance in West Virginia it's illegal
in Maryland it's legal what if someone
from you know lives in Maryland where
it's legal and they're and they and a CI
is like hey you want to you know hang
out we're going to the range and then go
to the range and they drive to West
Virginia and then they're leaving and so
they're like we're gonna go chill my
buddy's house and they go to chill's
house and then someone says hey you want
to bring some of this stuff over to us
that'd be really cool and they go oh
yeah sure I guess boom gotcha
talking about crossing state lines with
something illegal or whatever and you
kind of like the only you might not even
know where the state line is you said
it's called ghost ghost crime ghost
truck so ghost drugs is a really
prominent one in there so if the drugs
were there or not you still committed
the crime so they're going to arrest you
with no drugs just the well they said
they were going to they showed up to
meet to go buy it and the other one was
Ghost what was the other one um it's a
conspiracy to commit fraud fraud and
again I'm not an attorney I'm not a
lawyer I've not studied law but these
are the stories you hear inside you know
when everyone in prisons innocent if you
ask them I didn't do it you know but the
stories you hear they're I mean they're
tragic you know and I mean I like what's
an example uh well
foreign
it's hard you're not supposed to when
you get out you're not really supposed
to tell people stories and stuff make up
a story that's that's comparable but not
related to any actual person
um I mean like give us a gist of like
what it would be like
um sorry I'm sorry what's your question
I don't want you to to spill the beans
on anyone's actual life story so could
you make up something that's Akin so we
understand what it would be like
like um like what's what's a fictitious
example of what a tragic story would be
in these circumstances so like uh when I
was in I tell you what broke me
everyone's got a cell phone where I'm at
there's a lot of Contraband in there I
mean people were bringing in like
WingHouse wings at night they were doing
runs it was absolutely I don't know how
that happened I didn't see anything
wings are awesome yeah I'm actually
blind on both eyes and can barely hear
yeah
yeah um but uh there was one guy um I
was staying behind uh reading the book
and I heard a guy uh singing happy
birthday to like his three-year-old on a
cell phone he's crying kind of in
between and like that was absolutely
trash to me and this guy's in for for
marijuana you know what I mean I wanted
to put webcams in these prisons for
about 15 years I just even if people if
the guards are watching you have or
anyone have a conversation with their
family I mean at least they're having a
conversation that's why I asked you
about isolation earlier like
psychological isolation well I know the
place I was at used to be a women's camp
and uh they actually had the ability to
FaceTime their families like women have
different treatment than the men do in
prisons well that sounds like a Title IX
violation yeah well the only thing I
hate about the last story is that it
came out you know a couple months late
because I would have much rather
preferred going to a women's prison yeah
we did we only talked a little bit I
think we're gonna go super chats pretty
soon right now we only touched on
Surface on level at that last story but
I think your story was actually really
interesting all right we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already but
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends and timcast.com become
a member because I remember his only
uncensored show coming up for 11 pm
faster yeah there we go put that on 2.5
speed put that on one point put that on
point five if you want to really
understand what I said uh we're gonna
have that members only shot by
timcast.com at about 11 pm
let's read your super chats Tiberius
19 says
hey Tim what makes parallel economy
censure resistant do sensor resistant is
it just the fact that it's a separate
entity or is it something else
the company itself still there there's a
there's a chain with links and each link
is a weak point you've got your domain
hosting you've got your servers you've
got your financial transactions you've
got your social media any one of those
can snap and break the chain and harm
your business we have to keep forging
new links and replacing as many as we
can
parallel economy is a company that does
not have the insane censorship policies
of some of these other big financial
transaction firms so you're not going to
get banned because you hosted an
interview with someone who has naughty
opinions whereas some of these other big
firms they will nuke you in two seconds
so it's uh one step at a time there
still is the risk that card processors
in the back end like big Banks
they can still they can still shut you
down what you do there
um you need the Maga bank I guess so you
know maybe you need a billionaire to
open a Maga Bank
I guess
all right
let's grab some more super jets
marked ashamed says the student loans
have become the biggest short position
against the US economy even bigger than
the big short of the housing market in
2008. most of the debt that is to be
forgiven is in hedge funds so that is
200 profit yeah somebody mentioned
if somebody owes like a hundred grand
and they get 10K you know in their loans
paid down all that money is going to
these these lenders and your interest is
still going to crank your your Lo your
loan payments back up so it's like not
really doing much other than funneling
more money to Big to Big Banks
it's crazy
all right so let's grab some more Super
chats
Emil Koloff says I just I just poured a
huge drink and Tim said Civil War will
Frick me there you go man stay safe
Balian says so are you going to
criticize MTG for him for her hypocrisy
in demanding the censorship of kiwi
Farms due to the fact she's being
tricked into believing one of their mods
is responsible for her sweating if you
want to know more check out rickada's
video I saw that
um if Marjorie Taylor green is wrong
about this because I I don't know the
full details for one I do not believe
kiwi Farms should be censored and I do
think that whoever's in this wedding is
absolutely lying because we've been
experiencing something similar and um I
will uh I'll reach out to Marjorie and
make sure she's not making a mistake
um she should not be calling for
censorship and if that's the case that
would be hypocritical and and and bad
very bad so uh you know I'll reach out
maybe we'll have her back on the show at
some point when we can
Joshua Mark says G Prime 85 on the one
show I've caught live all year that's
karma for buying the completely awesome
awesome breaking bread Club print I bet
Ian thoughts
breaking bread Club print there was a um
a couple of strips I did called it was
based on The Breakfast Club it was like
a little joke so there's this uh
Christian girl who was caught having a
Bible in her book bag or something from
school and the dad says you go out and
get pregnant and have an abortion right
now and the sequel to that was uh
there's this bad boy in the Detention
Facility you know it's like Breakfast
Club her she got detention the bad boy
got detention he's like uh so what are
you in here for you know and he has a
Maga hat basically so the joke was that
it's now the cool thing to be a
republican slash conservative so this
fine individual I guess bought prints
for me and uh I don't know
what Ian would have sounds like Karma to
me yeah that's awesome get what you
deserve
all right
James Morgan says will you be signing
bands to Tim cast records is there an AR
rep to contact for possible submissions
no yes and no um we are going to be
signing bands
we have to figure out how to do it
Carter Banks is the go-to guy for all of
that stuff and I don't know where we are
with that right now we just have to
release like our own music and then I'll
put it this way
you know uh we have the song coming out
at midnight uh eastern time so it's like
was that 9 00 p.m yeah L.A time yeah a
large portion of our viewers are
actually on the west coast too not the
biggest but you know so that'll be
easier for you guys if it works
if the songs we put out succeed and
generate revenue and you know it's also
about building culture that means if the
song succeeds in getting play to a
certain degree I'm not super worried
about returns profit-wise if we get
returns marketing wise
but if the if the songs can can generate
Revenue to the point where we can expand
the operation we will otherwise the
reality is US putting out songs becomes
like a vanity project a thing we like to
do that helps generate Buzz for the
projects we're working on to put it
simply marketing value will exist in all
of them all the music stuff we do if it
generates Revenue then we start signing
more and more bans and ramping up
production otherwise it'll be like the
people who are here in-house and have
songs they want to publish will make and
publish but I really do want to uh at
least sign a few people for you know a
few deals to a certain degree maybe a
couple EPS to start we'll figure it out
I don't know how we can take submissions
we got to figure that out too there's
like legal things you got legal Hoops
you got to jump through if you want to
take solicitations or something like
that
all right Keegan Mooney says I am
outraged from Tim's slander from last
night that Jordan B Peterson didn't say
to watch Attack on Titan I implore you
to watch the 22 second video Jordan
Peterson on watching anime I look
forward to a retraction give your heart
to him give your heart uh well did he
say to watch watch Attack on Titan I
don't know it sounded like a deep fake
well the reason why I thought it could
be true you've seen it right uh some of
it yeah we've not seen not all of it
what the Jordan Anderson do you think or
the show you're talking about the show
Attack on Titan there's a lot of animes
I've started I haven't found Attack on
Titan is like watching a show based on a
Jordan Peterson lecture yeah it's it's
like a race of people who are demonized
for historical oppression and racism and
there's like the there they're called
the ldns and there's one they're like
we're the good ones we're we're teaming
up with the other countries because
aldians are bad and then there's other
people who are like basically being
punished and imprisoned because
thousands of years ago their people were
conquerors it's crazy I watched that and
I was like this sounds like a Jordan
Peterson were they able to transform at
that time or was that a punishment and I
can't remember when they became Titans
like everybody on the island not spoiled
totally just you're totally just
spoiling them yeah I've only seen the
first episode man I don't remember
um I think it's fair well I think it's
fair to spoil the first season it's
fairly old show but basically like the
show is people live in this big walled
triple walled City and their giant
humanoid monsters that eat people
outside they're called Titans and then
you discover like basically in the first
few episodes I think that people can
transform into Titans and you know I
don't know what else did you want to uh
well I mean if they're spoiler content I
don't know I just I've read a lot about
the series I don't know what is and is
not a spoiler I mean talking about the
good and bad ldns is a huge spoiler okay
yeah I'll ask is the planet called Titan
that they're on nope I think it's called
Earth interesting yeah they're in this
walled City
I guess I shouldn't say too much but
yeah it's it's uh super I remember it
was like super nihilistic and dark and
gross oh the art is incredible yeah well
Jordan Peterson said watch it I'm
definitely going to watch it I'm trying
to be a better man I think it was a
Jordan Peterson deep fake that says to
watch it but I could be wrong all right
I gotta asked Jordan to his face Chuck
Taylor says please read this super chat
okay moving on
km says Brie Larson's version of metrics
Black Sheep is way better the song from
Scott Pilgrim Vs the World sad to say
bro this is actually I agree
um but there's two versions The the so
there's one where uh it was re-uploaded
recently and there's a um
a vocal error I'll just call it that
like like Brie hits a sour note and they
didn't fix it in the in the first
release of It from the movie it's
perfect they did because basically what
they do is when she hits a sour note
they just fade it out and it works and
then in the later release I guess
they've upload a different version
um but I what I will say is
that song mine I could be wrong about
this metric made an album and they said
hey this song's not gonna make the album
we you know like we don't think it's
gonna fit it's not it's not the same
style it doesn't really fit in with the
rest of the songs and so when they were
making Scott Pilgrim they were like hey
this band is based on you guys and then
they were like oh that's great even
though the woman in the movie is like a
dick and so they're like hey we have the
song it didn't fit on an album you can
use this one I remember the first time I
saw Scott Pilgrim and I heard Black
Sheep I was like wow this song is really
good for like a movie song I was like I
wonder why I like it so much and I
looked it I was like oh it's my trick
it's like one of my favorite bands I
would say actually right now metric is
my favorite band they're amazing all
comes crashing is like all comes
crashing it's like the best song they've
ever made and I love like all their
albums so
I remember I got invited to a screening
of that one and uh I was a huge fan of
the comic at the time did you like the
movie the uh well okay so the version I
saw
um he ended up with knives at the end
and I thought that was a huge it was a
completely different ending really I was
one of the people who said the whole
point of this story is that he does not
end up with knives but he does in the
comic doesn't he he does in the comic
and he does in the movie but in the the
version of the movie that I saw he was
uh with knives Channel whatever this is
nerd talk I'm sure nobody knows no I
actually love that movie it's one okay
I've seen it several times but I also
think they botched the ending with uh he
ends up with Ramona at the end I still
think he should have ended up single
this is my opinion and uh I I would also
criticize him yeah well yeah I think
Scott needed to grow by the end of the
story and he needed to end up alone and
ask why am I alone and then I always
thought that Ramona should have been
like an evil witch who needed to be
cleansed of her evil exes and she needed
she used him to do it and then she would
vanish again I thought that would have
been a way better ending
no no disrespect to Brian Lee O'Malley I
was a huge fan but uh yeah my my my
nerdout is uh I'll say that the what if
did you watch Marvel's what if no the
doctor strange huge missed opportunity
you saw the doctor strange one yes so um
it plays into Multiverse of Madness uh
in the what if basically he's trying to
find a reality where Christine lives and
her death as a catalyst for him to
become Doctor Strange what should have
happened was he finally finds one
Universe where Christine gets to live
and it's where he sacrifices his hands
and his legacy to become doctor strange
but keeping her alive and that would be
the prequel to the actual first Doctor
Strange movie that would have been way
more epic could see that yeah but I
guess they wanted to use the character
and Multiverse of Madness I don't think
they know what they want Disney's
falling apart it is yeah the Marvel
movies are falling apart shulk is
getting blasted like people are it's I I
give it I give it look Miss Marvel was
the worst
She-Hulk is actually like
you know I watch it and it's like C
minus you know it's like oh watch it you
know whatever I'm really excited to see
Daredevil in it so you know I mean I I
watched everything up to um I started
watching the TV series you know Hawkeye
uh yeah the Captain America one can ever
I liked uh I liked uh what was wrong
with Scarlet Witch it was really really
good actually Wanda Vision One Division
I I thought that was I really liked it I
just skipped the first three episodes or
something I thought it was clever I
enjoyed the cleverness of it going
through different genres I mean
interesting filming I thought it was fun
something I haven't seen it before and
then like I got to be honest like that
made no like Multiverse of Madness ends
up making no sense they're turning every
movie into an Avengers movie and it's
really boring like the first Doctor
Strange was good it's about a guy and he
was in this journey now it's like every
movie is an Avengers movie and I'm just
like
anyway let's read some more
regill says Jeep rhyme excited to see
your amazing art in death mask the
second book in the Night Vale series by
Hugo nominated Excellence of elocution
razor fist available for pre-order now
welcome to the Iron Age oh yeah that was
a lot of fun actually I don't know um if
this is like widely known but yeah razor
fist the YouTuber uh the smack talker uh
was kind enough to ask me to illustrate
uh his the second book in a series it's
called um well this one's death mask
right
Max s says I would like to point out
that in the New York 19th District race
from earlier this week the Democrats and
media are bragging about beating the
Republican by two percent in a district
Democrats won by 12 percent in 2020 Red
Wave in November that's a 10-point swing
we'll see man we'll see
let's grab some more Super chats
all right Cody shifflett says was
wondering if you heard about Arizona
passing Bill about Arizona passing a
bill making it illegal to record cops
within eight feet if it's true I was
hoping to get y'all's thoughts on it
love you guys
well that's tough I mean why are you
walking within eight feet of a cop but
the question is if they're in in the in
the act of you know subduing somebody or
arresting somebody yeah I don't like it
I mean I I think you have a right to
have video evidence to support yourself
in court I do I mean if you get pulled
over I think you should be able to
record absolutely and I think it's
accountability is the measure we should
be asking for from police and you know
I'm again I have a lot of Leo friends
and I'm com I think they'd be fine with
that too the ones that probably aren't
fine with it
those are the ones that have questions
why they aren't do they have body cams
over there I don't know good question
because if I get pulled over and I start
filming and he comes within eight feet
of me am I breaking the rule now
what about your Teslas they have cameras
all over and so the first step is to get
a Tesla I suppose it's crazy they have
they have they have two they have a left
or right side camera front cam a back
camera dash cam and a cabin cam I
remember I parked once next to a Tesla
and I was close to it but I didn't hit
it or anything and I opened my door and
then I see on the dash it says recording
yeah what the hell yeah it's called
Sentry mode yeah and it films everything
you do yeah so I took a crap on it and
then I walked away I heard a story of
somebody somebody key to Tesla and it
recorded them doing it oh my yeah like
dude Teslas are scary man you stay away
I'm gonna get a Tesla dude the remote
control feature is crazy I never used it
because I've had Tesla for a while but
you can control the car remotely you can
be far away and then press a button and
the car will move with nobody in it yeah
it's really slow for obvious reasons but
it's kind of one of his plans elon's
plans I believe is to uh you know
displace Uber by allowing you to set
your Tesla to go Uber for you while
you're not using it and it'll drive
around pick people up and take them Uber
Uber is really really bad in my opinion
because
um these people who are doing this don't
realize the wear and tear on their
vehicle is is like eating away at the
money they're making you're basically
just selling the value of your car for a
short-term gain and then your car breaks
down runs out of gas it's kind of crazy
I saw somebody wouldn't do air
conditioning there's like four or five
days Uber driver won't put on the AC for
gas I always had the question what
happens when we have fully autonomous
vehicles that just drive themselves do
we even have car insurance companies
anymore nope do we see the car
manufacturer because uh they're a
technology interesting point uh I got
dropped my Tesla got dropped from our
insurance plan I don't know why weird
Tesla now offers insurance so here's
what I think if a car is on auto drive
and it crashes whose fault is it
Tesla
is it is it who gets sued it's got to be
the car's fault so what happens if what
happens if you get into you're driving
and you crash and the other person says
they were on Auto Drive I could tell
their hands were down the wheel and then
the guy the person drives like I was
driving I wasn't on I wasn't I wasn't on
autopilot they're like nope nope because
if it was Auto Drive I get to sue Tesla
well and then the insurance companies
are like we can't deal with whatever
that's about two different drivers the
same time you and the company
but here's the other thing too
um I have a Honda and it's got it's
basically got auto drive as well they
have Lane control or whatever and so you
put on cruise control and Lane control
and then it just drives on the highway
for you yep that's basically what Tesla
does
all right Aurora Isabella says hi Tim I
listen to your will of the People song
and I love it will you ever have a live
performance one day
we actually we jammed here with Carter
Pete perrotta and Adrian Norman Ian and
uh actually it was really good I have
harmonies for that song too no they're
not on the that uh recording of it but
I'd like to play those live yeah we're
probably going to re-upload the song to
the new timcast records page and then we
have another version so our song only
ever wanted is going up at midnight
tonight 1201 a.m tomorrow technically
and then I don't know exactly when but
we have another version so this song has
Rock in it but it's not a rock song I
guess the the best example the closest I
could probably get it to is Cosmic Love
by Florence maybe uh but we have another
version that's piano and violin and then
we're probably gonna do a performance in
here in the studio and then put that up
we should do a lounge version of will of
the people where it's like yeah
with some brushes
some brushes that'd be fun
let's see what we got here in the old
super jets let's grab some more super
jets
William Hinds says didn't the FBI know
the Russian interference was false at
the time they asked Facebook to censor
interesting question
unless they're just trying to get
negative stuff censored well here's a
good example the FBI a whistleblower
came out and said they were told by the
top brass not to investigate the laptop
because they didn't want to interfere in
the election then right before a midterm
they raided Trump's house
so uh how about that huh
how about is this election interference
yeah
DC says Biden saying the next Congress
will cancel 50k would be a disaster for
Dems 30 13 of adults have student loans
the remaining 87 percent aren't likely
to vote to pay for the 13 core choices
right that's why I think even now he's
betting on just pissing everybody off
maybe they want to lose man sometimes it
feels like they're so bad at what they
do they really do want Republicans to
win
like they're trying to like my favorite
conspiracy theory in this regard is that
China created wokeness and like pumped
it up through the media to destabilize
the country and now they're trying to
get rid of wokeness by creating fake
opposition yeah fun
dialectic dialectic yeah Max Stahl says
the Sandman is woke garbage dream homie
is naked in a bubble for all of the
first episode and one of the only
straight couples in the show chains a
black kid up in the basement
I mean the show's got it it's cringe but
the death episode is one of the greatest
pieces of uh visual media I've ever seen
it's on my toe watch list that is I
haven't started yet have you seen it
which one is death the death episode of
what show Sandman negative I haven't
seen it it's not about have you seen any
of this stuff like I don't want to ruin
it oh yeah we're talking about that a
couple nights ago amazing it's so good
it's just absolutely brilliant yeah Neil
Gaiman is a good author he wrote with
Terry Pratchett which I absolutely loved
his work he did good Omens which was an
incredible TV show even though it was
one of my favorite books as well I was
like this is amazing but he's a little
woke so yeah I mean I guess it's
probably par for the course is death one
of the characters in the show yeah and
then there's an episode basically about
death and it's really good yeah it's so
good
all right now let's talk smack to Matt I
shouldn't say this I once talked smacked
about him uh Neil Gaiman I was but this
I was just a little face to face no no I
was uh tweeting you know I was just this
little account at the time and I guess
he found his name and he's like hey
don't be I don't know he said something
I'm like whoa who invited you to this
conversation and he was like really uh
like he jumped on me like wow I think I
had said something like I like only one
of his stories or something like that I
liked Coraline and uh or Stardust or
something yeah yeah he's like well you
know I'm I'm not gonna pretend like I
know what he said buddy yeah why'd you
show up did you ever write draw for
other people's Comics I mean I know you
just did one recently uh well yeah I
mean that's technically my job it's um
like people just you know freelance me
they say hey here's some money and you
can do the illustration so for instance
I was working on razor fists I just did
um illustrations like black and white
illustrations like Frank Rosetta cool
um when was the last time I did a big
job like um
I don't know for a while I've been doing
like Indiegogo campaigns in like my Etsy
shop and stuff so like I have a series
uh a comic series that's I don't really
have time to work on uh two series
actually
um so it's really a matter of finding
time to be honest you get approached by
Marvel and DC no never no I I would be
very surprised if they would even talk
to me yeah no they would never work with
me would you work with them
um not under their current leadership
um I don't I mean first of all I don't
even think it's like remotely possible
because of my reputation and stuff but
even if for some reason they would hire
me
um I don't work super well with other
people especially like editor types and
like um they have IPS already so you
have to work within the bounds of what
they would uh oh the character would
never do this and I don't really like
working within boundaries like that I
want to be able to do whatever I want to
do and um so I I like the Indie I like
Indie stuff so I have a couple of series
that I've been writing and drawing
um I have one black and white horror
slash romance slash action story I have
another one with like a Derpy
um Mecca suit pilot
it's called Mary Sue but the idea is
that I want to take the tropes of like
they complain about how there's not a
lot of strong female characters
um or they're too perfect and my idea
was I want to take a character who's
nothing but imperfections she has this
power suit that she doesn't deserve and
the joke is that she goes on these
amazing quests and fights monsters and
Pirates and stuff but she she keeps
failing and nobody wants her to save the
day because she keeps ruining everything
around and the joke is that she does not
deserve to have this power suit and it's
kind of like a comedy action but also I
think it's quite well written if you ask
me it's like I like the idea of a
character with imperfections and
especially a female character with
imperfections because so many like
She-Hulk and stuff like that the
conversation is
there's all these lady characters that
have their biggest problem is that
they're compared to like male characters
or Society is against them it's like no
no let's have a female character with
real imperfections you know she's a derp
you know she's clumsy she's she's
terrible with guys but she wants to have
you know dates but you know guys look at
her like she's a disease you know they
avoid her and there'll be a lot of
related to that I could think it would
actually reach a lot of people on a on a
real level yeah and it would be funny it
would be amazing for me to work with a
publisher I've talked to a couple of
Publishers but I think they it's either
the rejection for some reason or I don't
know if they are allergic to my name or
all right let's read some more Super
chats Kevin Bella says I wish Tim was on
this latest episode of JRE with Mark you
would have asked the real questions Joe
missed so many opportunities oh oh geez
oh no I guess Joe you have to invite me
on and then bring Mark Zuckerberg back
that was so that's how it happened the
first time on Twitter yeah yeah people
were you know critical of Joe because he
didn't get to the core of like these
deeper cultural issues and then Joe and
I ended up having a conversation and
then Joe invited me on his show and then
Joe was like bro you want to come back
on with the Twitter CEO and I was like
are you nuts yes yes and then we did it
was great all right Reed Boone says
today I had to say goodbye to my beloved
16 year old dog and best friend Obama
Tim please say that thing you say about
the pain of losing a dog
so the way I describe it is you have all
of this great joy that builds up over
the 16 years you had with your best
friend and then when that dog passes it
all gets released at once all of those
memories and all of that love getting
released at the exact same time it's a
powerful feeling so I view it as you
know it's painful at first but you have
to realize that it's a good feeling
because all of that feeling only exists
because you had that that dog for as
long as you did or that loved one or
whoever and it is just like it was all
built up all that goodness and then all
at once so you might be crying but you'd
be smiling because that pain you're
feeling is proof of the the amazing The
Amazing best friend you just had and
lost and all the the great you know
times you shared he says Ian please say
something about how much of a good girl
Obama was Bama good job Bama best girl
best girl
Jason Jackson's just listened to only
ever wanted Spotify and I love it how
it's not out yet
unless in some places he's a pirated
song of all time
I don't know the only thing that's up on
our Spotify is the theme songs for uh
inverted World which the season two one
actually is a really good song I love
playing and will of the people and then
the the Retro 8-bit will of the people
that Carter made
yeah
all right let's see we'll grab a cup
we'll just grab a couple more here
did uh let's see which had stopped yep
no
no back to us no it's fine Alberto
chiprest says She-Hulk will do to
Daredevil what Hawkeye did to Kingpin I
won't forgive them for that
what is what is what do you mean I'm not
sure I understand was Kingpin the
villain in Hawkeye I didn't see it yeah
and then like you think he's dead but
now they're bringing him back in Echo I
think it is so I think it's interesting
uh They're bringing back Daredevil I
think they're bringing back Jessica
Jones uh Luke Cage they're bringing them
all all of them back but uh you know
look man as a big fan of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it is collapsing it's
become a soap opera you know it's it's
very soapy I mean again people are dying
they're cupping back I I really don't
like I are they are they going somewhere
I don't know if there's an end game to
this no no playoffs well here's the
issue
the first Iron Man was a character Story
the first store was a character Story
the first uh Captain America was a
character story then they did sequels
follows up on those characters the uh I
thought all of the first three Iron Man
movies were really good I liked all of
the Captain America movies but Captain
America was just Avengers the first one
was Captain America then the second one
was mini Avengers Soldier yeah then the
third one Civil War was Avengers
fighting each other
Thor I guess they got worried because
people didn't like dark world so they
made the Thor Comedy Hour starring Techo
ytt just fun that's a great movie but
but then they made love and thunder
which is the clown hour with like a ytt
featuring Thor and it's just like
they've lost it I haven't seen it yet
it's good I mean I like it but my point
is that it's just really off like the
whole MCU is just chaos now and now
they're gonna make blade so what
vampires exist they're gonna do the
mutants so what mutants have always
existed how do you do Charles Xavier or
whatever man if they ruin blade I won't
forgive them yeah maybe I want to place
people to this again The Infinity
Gauntlet oh maybe let's talk us out and
I'll tell you a little bit about this
all right everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends and head
over to timcast.com become a member one
of the members only show coming up at 11
PM uncensored not family friendly you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me at timcast Adam you want
to shout anything out
um you can follow me on social media if
you'd like I uh it's just pictures of my
family and me doing terrible hilarious
things it's a atom not that one guy
Johnson with uh periods in between the
words
we also have Mr G Prime 85 you want to
shout anything out that's it I'm G Prime
85 and you guys can follow me on
Instagram Twitter and uh I post I poop
post all the time it's great who post I
like that nice job uh and I'm Ian cross
and I want to tell you if you do like
Marvel or want to like Marvel or want to
understand why people like Marvel it is
because of things like this is The
Infinity Gauntlet episode number one or
issue number one this is one of the
greatest Comics ever written in my
opinion I haven't read them all but this
is I mean they made movies they made
many many movies about this this is
where it all begins this is and it's
it's not I don't know I didn't see the
movie but the comic's incredible it's
about life and death and love and hate
and and utilitarianism it's fantastic uh
see you later all right you guys thank
you so much for joining me on this
eventful Thursday night uh my thoughts
are certainly with you to the owner of
Bama I'm very sorry that she passed away
I'm so glad you got to spend so many
good years with her you guys can follow
me on Twitter and minds.com at Sour
Patch lights as well as sour patchlets
Tommy we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks